So I hope we can.
My plan is to finish this today.
So,
and then we'll go into the more concrete
details now that you've got some sense
of the way that a narrative like this
can unfold.
So if you remember,
we were just leaving this terrible
little bar,
which I think was called the red lobster
or something like that where the Fox and
the cat had met the coachman and the
coachman is obviously someone who takes
you somewhere.
Um,
it takes you on a trip.
And the coachman basically revealed
himself first.
He kind of looks like a,
I guess a somewhat jolly old man,
although his expression doesn't
precisely read as Jolie.
And then he reveals himself as something
positively say tannic and that's enough
to terrify these two bit thugs,
the Fox and the cat who think they're
tough but really are tough at all.
And so they see at some point what
they're really tangled up in.
And I think I mentioned to you that that
was something akin young had this idea
that people's shadows reach all the way
down to hell,
which is a very frightening concept.
And what he meant by that is,
is that if you take a look at the
impulses that drive you,
that are actually malevolent,
if you can admit to such impulses that
if you basically follow those all the
way down to their origin,
you find some very nasty things.
And what you find down there basically
is what allies you with people who've
done terrible things and that that's not
a very pleasant experience,
I would say.
Although one thing that's worth thinking
about is that it is something that can
protect you against being very,
very badly hurt.
Because one of the things that
characterizes people who develop
posttraumatic stress disorder is that
they're often naive and then they
encounter something that's really not
within their framework of thinking.
And it's usually something bad.
And because there,
there isn't anything in their
philosophy,
their way of looking at the world that
has prepared them for that,
they ended up fragmented and devastated.
And so it's actually protective to you.
If you can figure out what your,
what your full range of capabilities is,
because that can help you understand
other people a lot better.
And,
and,
uh,
to be wiser and more careful in your
actions.
It's also useful,
I think,
if you want to convince yourself to act
properly because if you regard yourself
as harmless,
which is a big mistake,
then nothing you can do is really that
bad,
right?
Because you're harmless after all.
But if you understand that you're
seriously not harmless,
then that can make you a lot more
careful with yourself.
And I would say that,
that that's especially true.
Maybe when you're dealing,
when you have kids and you start dealing
with your kids.
If you know that what you're capable of
because you're human,
then that can motivate you to be much
more careful with what you say and do.
And I don't mean cautious.
I don't mean timid.
I don't.
I don't mean any of that.
I just mean that you want to keep things
pristine between you and your children,
let's say,
because that way they're on your good
side and you want them on your good side
because children who get on their
parents bad side suffer very badly for
it.
And sometimes it's because they're
literally abused,
but more often it's because they get,
while they get abused,
let's say,
or neglected in much more subtle ways.
And you're definitely capable of that.
I mean all you have to do is think about
the way that you've interacted with
someone that you've decided to not like
or maybe someone you genuinely don't
like,
you know,
and that can range from just not paying
any attention to them,
especially if they're doing something
good to really pursuing them and making
their life miserable.
And you can certainly do that with your
family members and you can do that with
your intimate partners and you can do
that with your friends and you can do it
with yourself.
And so it's really worth knowing that.
So.
Well the Fox thinks he's a royal rule
breaker,
but he's really just a two bit thug and
this is where he,
he learns that.
So sorry,
I have a new phone and I'm kind of
stupid with.
It's still so.
Well,
hypothetically,
that'll work,
but it probably won't.
Anyways.
The coach ones got these guys in his
grasp now regardless.
And partly because they're already down
this road and they can't back off and
partly because he also offers them more
money than they've seen before.
And so as bad as they are,
they're going to get worse.
Many of you,
I presume,
have seen breaking bad and that's a
really good example of the,
of the incorporation at least in part or
maybe the possession by the shadow from
the Union perspective,
right?
Because you have this ordinary high
school teacher who really thinks that
he's an ax and his family as well.
You know,
like your typical persona,
roughly speaking,
he's just a normal guy.
But part of the reason that he's a
normal guy is because he actually hasn't
been put in abnormal circumstances.
And then all of a sudden he is.
And he has a genuine moral conundrum,
right?
He's going to die of lung cancer and
his.
He has a son who's got a lot of health
problems and he's terrified that he's
going to leave his wife and his child
behind with nothing.
And then of course as the story.
And so he decides to do something that
temporarily,
that he regards as what they would
normally regard as reprehensible.
And of course he just gets tangled up in
that.
But then as the story unfolds,
you see that there's,
it's more complicated because it's not
that he was just innocent,
good,
and he decided to turn bad.
He's also very resentful and angry and
it's partly because he's a bit of a
pushover at the beginning or maybe more
than a bit of a pushover.
And also that he didn't really fulfill
his own potential and that,
you know,
he had friends who walk down the
entrepreneurial path and maybe they
weren't quite fair to him,
but whatever.
He ends up not very successful as a high
school teacher.
So he's really angry about that.
And so there's more motivation for him
opening up the door to,
to the terrible elements of his
personality than just the fact that he's
got good motivations to do so.
And that,
that unfolds,
you know?
And so you see that warps and twists and
is resentful.
Character increasingly manifest
themselves as he walks down this road to
really total brutality.
And it,
it's,
it's quite good.
Um,
there's a book called ordinary men
that's a lot like that.
I don't think I've mentioned that to you
before,
but ordinary men is a book about,
it's the best book of it's type.
Maybe it's the only book of its type.
It's possible,
but it's plotted much like breaking bad
in some sense.
It's a story about these German
policemen in early stages of World War
II and they were guys who were old
enough to be raised in Germany really
before the hitlarian propaganda came out
in full force,
you know,
if you were a teenager,
say in the 19 thirties you are going to
be pulled right into the propaganda
machine and maybe you were part of the
Hitler youth and like you were raised in
that,
you know,
but if you were older than you were
raised before that and you're not as
amenable to propaganda once you're older
than about.
While I would say about 22 or something
like that.
It's,
it's pretty young actually.
If you're gonna make a soldier,
you have to get a soldier young because
once people are in their early twenties,
say they're kind of,
they already have their personality
developed.
Anyways,
these policemen were sent into Poland
after the Germans marched through and
uh,
you know,
it was wartime and there is this
hypothesis in Germany that the Jews in
particular,
we're operating as a fifth column and
undermining the German war effort
because of course the Germans blamed the
Jews and a variety of other people for
actually setting up the conditions that
made the war necessary.
And so when the police were sent into
Poland,
they were also required to make peace
roughly speaking.
And so they started up by.
They started out by rounding up all the
Jewish men between 18 and 65 and
gathering them in in stadiums and then
shipping them off on the trains.
But that isn't where they ended.
They ended in,
in very,
very dark place.
I mean,
these guys were going out in the field
with naked pregnant women and shooting
them in the back of the head by the end
of their training.
And what's really interesting about that
is that is that their commander told
them that they could go home at any
time.
So this is,
this is not one of those examples of
people following orders and the reason
they didn't,
roughly speaking,
there's many reasons,
but one of the reasons they didn't is
because they didn't think it was
comradely,
so to speak,
to leave their guys they were working
with to do all the dirty work and run
off,
you know.
And that's really,
that's really an interesting fact,
you know,
because you in,
in different circumstances,
you wouldn't think about that as
reprehensible,
right?
You'd think,
well that's part of teamwork and under
rough circumstances and that's at least
in part how they viewed it.
And they were also made physically ill
multiple times physically and
psychologically ill by the things that
they had to do.
But they kept doing them anyways.
So it's one step at a time.
And that's the thing is that you end up
in very bad places one step at a time.
So you got to watch those steps.
Anyways.
Pinocchio has now decided after his
latest misadventure to return to the
proper pathway,
he's off to school again and uh,
he's still pretty naive,
although perhaps not as much so as he
was before.
And so he decides that he's going to do
things right.
He's going to go get educated,
he's going back to school,
he's going to take the conventional
route to discipline and do and be a good
boy roughly speaking.
And so he's off to school.
And the Fox waylay them.
Again.
This is a really interesting scene.
Took me quite a long time to unpack this
too.
And so the Fox first of all starts out
by acting like he's sympathetic again,
sympathetic towards Pinocchio.
And so he's empathetic,
you could say.
And so this is an interesting analysis
of empathy.
So what happens is,
is the Fox Convinces Pinocchio through a
variety of maneuvers that he's actually
not feeling very well,
that he's sick.
He really convinces him that he's a
victim.
And one of the things,
I had a graduate student named Maya
chicken who who had worked with the UN
and in Bosnia and she had toured some of
the mass grave sites there and we wrote
a paper one time called you can either
remember nor forget what you don't
understand,
and it was a paper about the idea,
for example,
it was partly about the idea that we
should never forget the Holocaust and
that the idea there is that what we
should never forget it and we shouldn't
repeat it,
but the thing is,
if you don't understand how those things
come about,
you can't really remember them.
Right?
You think about them as a set of
historical facts,
but that's not the kind of remembering
that actually makes any difference.
You have to understand the causal
pathways.
You have to understand how a society
would transform in that manner.
And more importantly,
you have to understand the role of the
individuals within that society.
Unless you're going to assume that
they're so completely unlike you,
that there's no connection whatsoever.
In which case you haven't remembered it
at all.
You haven't learned anything at all
because the right lesson from what
happened in the 20th century is this is
what human beings are like.
That's the correct blessing and you can
say,
well,
not me,
but you should,
but probably you too.
That's the thing probably and probably
me to at least under normal
circumstances.
Anyways,
the Fox Convinces Pinocchio that he's
sick.
He performs a lot of tricks to do this.
Now you could say that Pinocchio is
susceptible to this because maybe
they're still part of him that's looking
for the easy way out,
and so one of the things that Maya and I
found when we were writing this paper,
we were looking at the discourse that
precedes genocide in genocidal states
and the enhancement of a sense of
victimization on the part of one of the
groups.
Usually the group that's going to commit
the genocide.
First of all,
their senses,
their sense of being victims is much
heightened by the demagogues who are
trying to stir up this sort of hatred.
So they basically say,
look,
you've been oppressed in a variety of
ways and these are the people who did it
and they're not going to stop doing it
and this time we're going to get them
before they get us.
It's something like that.
And so there's something very
pathological about the enhancement of
victimization,
which is well,
see that the problem as far as I'm
concerned with it is it's not.
It's not thought through very well
because there's.
There's a point that's being made and
the point is that people have been
oppressed and they suffer and that's
true that point,
but that's.
But then the proper framework from
within which to interpret that I believe
is that that's characteristic of life.
You can't take it personally in some
sense and you can divide the world
neatly into perpetrators and victims and
you certainly can't divide the world
then assume that you're only in the
victim class and then assume that that
gives you certain access to certain
forms of redress.
Let's say it gets dangerous very rapidly
if you do that sort of thing.
So for example,
one of the things that characterized the
Soviet Union,
and this was particularly true in the 19
twenties,
but,
but afterwards is so the Soviets were
very much enamored of the idea of class
guilt.
So for example,
although it wasn't only about 40 years
previously that the serfs had been
emancipated,
they weren't much more than slaves.
Right.
And so that was the bulk of the Russian
population.
They were bought and sold along with the
land.
So they had been emancipated and some of
them,
many of them had turned into independent
farmers and some of them had become
reasonably prosperous because at least
in principle I presumed a certain
proportion of them from being crooked,
but I presume a larger proportion from
actually being able to raise food.
And of course at that time the bulk of
the Russian food was produced by these
relatively successful peasant farmers
and relatively successful would mean
maybe they had a brick house or
something and maybe they had a couple of
cows and maybe they were able to hire a
few people.
And so,
you know,
it wasn't like they were massive land
owners or anything.
But I've talked to you a little bit
about the preto principle and the notion
that in any domain of activity,
a small proportion of people ended up
producing most of what's in that domain
of activity.
The same was true in Russia with regards
to these peasant farmers.
Some of them were extraordinarily
efficient and they produced most of
Russia's food.
When the communists came in,
they described those,
those land holders as parasites
essentially predicated on the Marxist
idea that if someone had extracted
profit from an enterprise that they had
basically stolen that profit from from,
from the people say that they had
employed or otherwise oppressed.
And so you could be a member of the Ku
lack,
k u,
l a,
c,
a k,
k,
u l a k.
You can be a member of the Kulak class.
And then because you were a member of
that class,
you are automatically guilty.
And so what happened was,
and you got to think this through to
really understand what happened.
So what happened was the intellectual
communists were sent out in cadres out
into these little towns to find people
who would help them round up the Kulaks.
Now you've got to think about what a
small town is like because so imagine
you're in a town and there's three or
four people or maybe 10 people or
something like that who are a little
more successful than everyone else,
and a certain number of people are going
to be fine with that and maybe even
happy about it because they regard those
people as particularly productive and
you know,
as stalwart members of the community,
regardless of their flaws.
But there's gonna be some people who are
not happy about it at all that are going
to be very resentful about that and
jealous.
And so those are going to be people
whose characters I would say are of the
less positive type.
And so when the intellectuals came in
and described the reason that these
people should be treated as parasites
and profiteers,
then it was the resentful minority in
those towns.
And that would be the kind of guy that
hangs around in the bar all the time and
is completely unconscientious and fails
at everything and then blames everyone
else for it.
The intellectuals came in and said,
here's this is unfair that this happened
to you.
You've actually been victimized and now
it's your opportunity to go have your
revenge.
And so that's exactly what happened.
Now in some of the villages,
some of sometimes the peasants would
actually surround the that the,
the,
the farmsteads have these more
successful people and try to defend
them.
But that never worked out for very long.
And so then these mobs,
these angry mobs would go into the farm
houses and strip the place right down to
nothing.
And they pack these people up and sent
them on trains with no food at out to
Siberia where there was no place to
live.
And so that they were packed into
houses,
you know,
maybe they had a square meter each to
live in.
And all the children died of typhoid.
And,
and,
and many of them froze to death.
Many,
many people died.
Millions of people died.
As a consequence of the Deq lack,
ization had least in,
in as a consequence of its total effect.
So what happened then was that a,
there wasn't any food produced and so
then 6 million Ukrainian starve to death
in the 19 twenties,
which is something you never hear about,
right?
You never hear about that.
Why do you never hear about that?
That's a question worth asking.
You know,
it was an absolute catastrophe.
They used to.
So these people were starving.
Break to the point of cannibalism,
right?
I mean it was ugly.
It was ugly as anything you could
possibly imagine if you were a mother
and.
And so you're supposed to handle your
grain into the central committee,
mostly for distribution into the cities.
You didn't get to keep any for yourself.
And so maybe then afterwards,
if you were a mother,
you'd go out in the fields that had
already been harvested and you pick up
individual grains of wheat and if you
didn't turn those in nature,
that was death for you.
So that's how far it was pushed so.
Well.
So that's a little story about how
victimization,
how the idea of victimization and
perpetration can get out of hand
extraordinarily rapidly.
And so whenever people are beating the
victim drum,
you know,
they'll cover that up with,
with,
uh,
empathy.
Roughly speaking,
we're speaking on behalf of the
oppressed.
It's like maybe you are,
but maybe you're no saint because you
know,
you're so sure that you're a saint and
you're only speaking from the position
of good.
It's highly unlikely.
Anyway,
so Pinocchio is enticed into believing
that he's a victim.
Now,
the logical part of that is that it is
the case that you know,
you can make a very strong case that
every human being is in some sense
involved in a tragic enterprise,
right?
Because you're biologically vulnerable.
You're not what you could be as a
biological specimen,
right?
You're full of imperfections and plus
you're going to be sick and those you
love are going to be sick and everything
ends up in death.
And so that there's a very tragic
element to that.
And then by the same token,
you're also subject to the theoretical
aspect of your culture,
right?
Because it's forcing you to be a certain
way all the time,
it socialization does that you're
required to modify your own intrinsic
nature in order to come into conformity
with the broader community and you can
think about that from the Piagetian
sense,
which is the socialization makes you a
more and more sophisticated person and,
and there's some truth in that,
but you can also be subject just to
tyranny,
you know,
and you see,
I see people in my practice,
for example,
who've had very tyrannical fathers for
example.
Sometimes they have to radical mothers
as well,
but they're not so much encouraged to,
to integrate properly into social
community as they are harassed and
abused and made to feel insufficient and
you know,
basically subject to tyranny.
And so it's quite an.
And that's true of everyone to some
degree,
you know,
you,
you come to university and there's a
tyrannical aspect to it.
You're in.
Especially in a big institution like
this,
you're not really marked out as an
individual in any sense.
You know,
you're,
you're a number along with 60,000
other people and you know,
there there's something cold and
impersonal about that which is well
represented in the design of this
classroom.
Say and,
but by the same token,
you know that the university provides
you with an identity while you're
exploring an intellectual landscape.
You know,
you have a lot of freedom compared to
the vast majority of people.
Perhaps you don't have as much freedom
as you might if you compared it to some
utopia notion of freedom,
but in any real world sense,
you're unbelievably well protected by
the university partly because it stamps
you with the identity student,
which is a respectable identity and so
you can go off and educate yourself as
much as you can.
Well,
and everyone in society says that's
okay.
They carve out a protected space for
you.
So at the same time as you're being
tyrannized by the institution and,
and,
and forced in some ways also to adopt
the viewpoints,
say of the professors,
depending on the professor,
you're also the beneficiary of that.
Just like you're the beneficiary of this
huge industrial infrastructure that
underlies everything.
We do,
so anyways,
the fact that your life is tragic
necessarily and that you are subject to
oppression makes the victimization story
really easy to swallow,
but then there's dark side of that too,
and this is actually what happens with
Pinocchio.
So what happens here is that he's told
that he's ill and convinced that these
ill and they do use trickery and and and
so again,
you could look at him in some sense as
an innocent victim,
but the innocence,
the filmmakers do a good job of hedging
against the innocent interpretation
because what he's offered and accepts
because these ale is an easy way out and
so what the Fox basically tells him is
that he needs to have a vacation because
he's sick and he can go off to pleasure
island,
which is this place of impulsivity.
Roughly speaking in and whim.
It's like reversion to being two years
old in some sense,
and that he really needs that because
otherwise he's not going to be able to
live property.
He's not going to be able to recover his
health.
And so what Pinocchio is offered is the
opportunity to abandoned responsibility.
As a reward for adopting the guys that
victim and that's really worth thinking
about because one of the things I've
thought about for a long time is that
I've been trying to figure out what
gives people's lives meaning and tragedy
gives life its negative meaning and
nobody disputes that.
Even if you're nihilistic,
you're not going to dispute the fact
that tragedy gives life negative
meaning.
So when.
Now let's say that life is meaningless.
That isn't exactly what they mean.
They mean that life is suffering,
but there isn't anything transcendent
about it that you could set against that
suffering that's nihilism.
It's not that life is meaningless,
that would just be neutral.
It's like no one believes that and they
certainly don't act like they believe
it.
If you look at it technically and we
will as we progress through this class,
that in order to have any positive
meaning in your life,
you have to identify the goal and you
have to be working towards it and there
is a technical reason for that.
And the technical reason,
as far as I can tell is that the
circuitry that produces the kind of
positive emotion that people really like
is only activated when you noticed that
your peers,
when you're proceeding towards a goal
that you value,
and so that means that if you don't have
a goal that you value,
you can't have any positive emotion.
So technically that's the incentive
reward system and it's the underlying
circuitry is dopaminergic and would not
circuitry is activated.
Then it's part of the exploratory
circuit.
It makes you,
it gives you the sense of being actively
engaged in something worthwhile and
that's you know,
you,
you tend to think of positive emotion is
something produced by reward,
but there's two kinds of positive
emotion.
One is the reward that's associated with
satiation and that's conservatory
reward.
And that's the reward you get when
you're hungry and you eat.
But the thing about eating when you're
hungry is that it destroys the framework
within which you are operating,
right?
It's time to eat what you eat and then
that frameworks no longer relevant.
So the consumer story reward eliminates
the value of framework.
And then you're stuck with what,
what are you going to do next?
And so the conservatory reward has with
its own problems.
But the incentive reward is constantly
what keeps you moving forward and
incentive reward because it's still
open.
Jack also is analgesic,
literally analgesics.
So if you're in pain,
you take opiates and that will cut the
pain,
but so well psychomotor stimulants like
cocaine or amphetamines and so it's
literally the case that if you're
engaged in something that's engaging and
you're working towards a goal that
you're going to feel less pain.
And you can see this happening with
athletes who you know,
they'll break their thumb or something
or maybe sometimes even the rankl and
they'll keep playing the game.
Of course afterwards they're suffering
like mad,
but the fact that they're so filled with
goal directed enthusiasm means that
whether pain systems are in some sense
shut off.
So that's an interesting thing because
what it suggests,
I mean then you could imagine,
I might say,
well how happy you are you that you've
made a certain amount of progress.
And if you think about it,
what you'd say is.
Well,
it depends on how much progress and in
relationship to what so hypothetically
you're going to be happier if you've
made quite a bit of progress towards a
really important goal and then you have
to think through what it means for a
goal to be really important because
that's not obvious.
Now you could say you're in this class
and you're listening to some information
and maybe there's two reasons for that.
You might find the information
interesting per se,
but let's forget about that for a
minute.
You need to listen to the information so
that you can do well on the assignment
so that you can do well in the class.
You need to do well in your classes so
that you can finish up your degree.
You need to finish up your degree so
that you can find your place in the
world.
You need to do that so that you're
financially stable and maybe you can
start a family and have a life and
that's all part of being a good person.
Something like that.
And so that's a hierarchy of goals and
you might say that being a good person
would be the thing,
however vaguely thought through.
That's at the top of that hierarchy.
And then when you're doing things that
serve that,
that ultimate purpose,
then you're going to find those more
meaningful and that meaning is actually
produced as a consequence of the
engagement of this exploratory circuit
that's nested write down in your
hypothalamus.
It's really,
really old.
It's as old as thirst and it's as old as
hunger.
It's really an old system.
And so you want to have that thing
activated.
I mean at least from a,
from a,
from a a while.
It isn't only from it he dominic point
of view,
you know,
it isn't a matter of being happy.
It's the wrong way of thinking about.
It's much more complicated than that.
It's,
yes,
that was actually.
I was just about to ask that.
Let's bring up like,
yeah,
because I'm just trying to understand
this,
I guess not relationship,
but the differentiation between hedonism
and satiation and you like going back to
when you mentioned that it's not that
life is meaningless,
but he didn't.
Them isn't exactly like it's not
satiation because at that point people
are just doing what they're doing for
the sake of doing.
It's not just for activation of the dove
and the dove into men are just started
dumping them in their job
system.
Um,
so I'm just trying to understand.
Well,
what I would say,
we're going to go into that a lot once
we're done this like a lot,
but I'll,
I'll,
I'll go over it briefly.
I mean it's not merely hedonism because
there is an analgesic and,
and also a fear reducing element to
pursuing the proper path.
Right?
So there's control of negative emotion,
but there's not just control of negative
emotion and generation of positive
emotion in the immediate future,
which is kind of what you'd think about
with regards to hedonism.
Actually,
Pinocchio takes a,
he dawning route next.
The problem with the he dornoch route is
that.
So the pursuit of pure happiness,
let's say,
is that what makes you happy in the next
minute might not be something that will
make you happy in the next hour.
Well,
you know that there's this car comic.
What's his name?
They called them Katie,
the one liners you talked about drinking
wine.
He said,
don't you know that's going to cause a
hangover?
He,
yeah,
at the end,
but the beginning of middle are
excellent and so that's really the
problem with hedonism,
right?
Is that to pursue something that makes
you happy in the immediate present risk,
sacrificing your well many things,
but at least let's say your hedonism in
the medium to longterm.
And of course that is one of the major
problems with drug use.
And alcohol is a really good example of
that because whatever he don't it kick
you might get from it that moment at
night you're going to pay for almost
completely or maybe even more so because
the next day you're much more jittery
and anxious and that's a.
that's a direct consequence of
withdrawing from the drug.
So when you're in,
when you have a hangover,
you're in alcohol withdrawal,
so that's how fast you,
you get roughly speaking,
addicted to it,
and so if you take another drink when
you're hung over,
it'll cure it,
but it's not a very useful care because
all you do is push the inevitable
hangover one more step into the future.
And so part of the problem with the
hedonic answer is happy when exactly and
over what period of time and also who's
happy because maybe something makes you
happy,
but makes your family miserable.
Now you could say,
well,
I don't care,
but you do care if you have to live with
your family because they're going to
take it out on you.
So,
so the,
the impulsive hedonism,
which is also fostered,
say by a positive emotion,
it tends to put people into a state of
the pursuit of short term hedonism.
It's not a good longterm or medium to
longterm solution.
I actually think that's why people
evolved conscientiousness,
right?
Because conscientiousness is not happy.
Conscientious people aren't
conscientious because it makes them
happy.
We're starting to think that they're
conscientious because they actually feel
terrible if they're just sitting around
doing nothing,
and so it's a way of staving off stress.
The stress that's related to enforce
leisure,
something like that.
You know,
you if you know industrious people,
some of you will have,
some of you are industrious,
some of you will have industrious
parents.
They just can't sit around and do
nothing.
They have to be working.
They don't feel good unless they're
working.
So what thing about conscientiousness is
that it involves continual sacrifice,
right?
You're doing difficult things in the
present,
hypothetically to make the future
better,
but that's not driven by hedonism,
by any stretch of the imagination and
conscientiousness is actually a pretty
good predictor of longterm life success
in stable societies because there's also
no point in being conscientious and
saving things up and storing things.
If a bunch of thugs are going to just
come in randomly and and take it all
away.
So conscientiousness actually only works
intelligently and societies that have
some medium to longterm stability,
you know,
because you can get wiped out by
hyperinflation too because
hyperinflation kills off the
conscientious people.
The people who accrue debts are thrilled
with hyperinflation,
kicks in because it wipes out their
debts.
But of course those debts are the things
they owed to people who were
conscientious enough to save.
So anyways,
Pinocchio was transformed into a victim
and he's offered this,
he's offered this identity and he takes
it.
Now,
it's partly because he's deceived and
manipulated,
but it's also partly because the fox
offers him the abandonment of
responsibility as payment for as payment
for adopting the victim identity.
So this is where his own lack of
morality,
let's say,
because this is all about Pinocchio.
Development as a character plays a role
in his demise.
So if I'm a victim than everyone else
owes me something and I don't have to
take any responsibility.
And so one of the things I've wondered,
here's something to think about.
It might be that the sense of meaning
that life can provide to you is
proportionate to the amount of
responsibility you decide to take on.
Not that'd be very strange if it was the
case,
you know,
because responsibility of course is a
kind of weight obviously,
and it's difficult to take on
responsibility,
but if any positive emotion that you
feel and your control of anxiety and the
control over pain is dependent on the
activation of these systems that watch
you move towards a desired goal,
then the more complete and weighty the
goal is,
the more kicked there's going to be in
the observation that you're moving
towards it.
And I,
you know,
you kind of already know this because
you'll,
you'll have observed in your own life
that when you're engaged in something
that you believe in,
that the time passes properly.
You know,
you can see this even if you're.
Maybe you're reading a paper and it's
actually related in some intelligible
manner to something that you want to
learn.
So even though it's difficult,
you get engaged in it,
you can remember it better.
You can process it better and you don't.
You're not so likely to fall asleep and
you're not so likely to want to find
distractions.
All of that you can get into it and it
would be very interesting if that was
proportionate to the degree of
responsibility that you're willing to
shoulder and I think you can make a
strong case for that.
I've also often wondered,
imagine you could offer people a choice.
Here's the choice.
You could say,
well,
your life isn't meaningful.
Denialists have got it right.
There's no meaning in your life and
because of that,
there's no reason for you to accept any
responsibility so you can live a
responsibility free life and maybe one
of the impulsive pleasure seeking better
responsibility for free life,
but the price you pay is that it doesn't
get to be meaningful.
Or you could say to someone,
no,
we're going to do the opposite.
We're going to say you can live a
meaningful life,
but it's only gonna.
Be as meaningful as the amount of
responsibility that you're willing to
bear.
And then you might say,
well,
what would people choose?
Because everybody also always makes
noises about wanting to have a
meaningful life.
But if the price you pay for that is the
adoption of responsibility,
that it's not so obvious that people
would choose meaning over,
no over pointless pursuits if they had
to,
if the benefit they got for choosing the
pointless pursuits was that they really
didn't have to care about anything they
ever did,
right?
Snow responsibility,
and that's really what Pinocchio is
offered and that's what the coachman
offers them.
And that's interesting because know so
far it's been the Fox and the and the
cat,
and they were kind of to bid hoods and
so the pathological pathway that they
offer Pinocchio is not the worst of the
pathological pathways,
but here at least as far as the
imagination,
the collective imagination that created
this movie is concerned is this is where
you get to the most pathological form
of,
let's call it temptation,
and that's the temptation to engage in,
to abandoned responsibility and to
engage in impulsive pleasure seeking
short term pleasure seeking.
So here's the Fox pretending to be a
Doctor Investigating Pinocchio's illness
and he makes some notes,
which is all just meaningless scribble,
right?
It's like white noise and it doesn't
matter that the arguments that he's
making is are completely incoherent and
it doesn't matter that he actually
doesn't know anything.
He what he's selling is easy to buy and
so Pinocchio buys it and by the end of
the conversation with the Fox,
he's pretty convinced that he's useless
and it needs a vacation.
No,
this is anita postage inedible situation
as well.
Charlie touched on the other lecture
mean
hmm,
that's fair.
Let's imagine that you have a child that
is a little on the neurotic side,
so high negative emotion and maybe one
that's also a little bit on the east
side,
so has a variety of,
let's say relatively minor ailments,
but the ailments nonetheless.
So what that means as a parent will say,
mother,
for this example,
because I want to use the eatable
example,
you have to make a decision all the time
about exactly how you're going to treat
that child.
One decision is,
well,
I'm not gonna.
You don't have to go to school today
because you're not feeling well.
It's like
fair enough,
but you make the same decision the next
day and do you make the same decision
the next day and let's imagine that you
enable the child to avoid responsibility
as a consequence of capitalizing on
their illness.
Well then that's not going to be very
good for the child.
The rule within a sickly child has to be
something like,
I'm going to push you right to your
limit because otherwise,
how is the person going to figure out
what they can do?
And if they can't figure out what they
can do,
then you're not going to be able to make
their way in the world at all.
And then that gets muddied very badly.
If you're not exactly sure that you want
them to make their way in the world.
You know,
maybe you're just as happy because you'd
be sitting at home alone if your child
was there with you and maybe you'd be
just as happy at some level if they
never grew up at all because then they
won't leave.
And so,
and maybe that's because you have a
terrible marriage and your lonesome.
You know,
maybe it's an abusive marriage and your
husband has chased away all your friends
so you don't have anything at all and
maybe that's because he didn't stand up
for yourself very well apart from the
fact that he was,
you know,
tyrannical and is central nature and so
then all those little warps in bands in
your psyche are going to manifest
themselves.
Right,
right.
In the background of every single one of
those decisions.
My daughter had a lot of illnesses when
she was an adolescent and they were very
serious and it was very difficult to
figure out what to do about that because
you couldn't exactly applied normative
rules.
Right.
And we always had to figure out if she
was
communicating her symptoms to us,
how seriously to take those.
And the answer was the least amount of
serious possible.
It's something like that because we
needed to do and she needed to know what
she could do in spite of the fact that
she had problems.
And one of the things I really tried to
instill in her,
and I think it worked,
is that you don't ever want to use it
your illness as an excuse for not doing
anything.
Not Consciously.
You know,
sometimes you might not know,
I'm not feeling well.
What can I do?
What you don't know,
right?
Because sometimes when you're not
feeling well,
you can do more than you think.
And sometimes you can do less than you
think.
It's not like it's obvious,
but sometimes it's obvious.
You know this little temptation flits
through your mind and you think,
well,
I don't really want to do what I'm doing
today and I'm not feeling very well so I
don't have to do it.
You do that 100 times,
then you don't know how sick you are
anymore and then you're.
Then you're in real trouble because not
only are you sick,
but you actually have.
You've muddied the waters and so you
have both problems then is you're
actually ill and you've betrayed
yourself by using that as an excuse not
to pursue your responsibilities and not.
I think if you do both of those,
both of those things happened to you at
the same time.
You're in real trouble.
It's really hard not to have that
happen.
So anyways,
Pinocchio gets enticed into believing
that he's the victim.
The fact that he's insufficient is used
as an excuse by the Fox and the and the
cat to offer him a trip to pleasure
island,
and this is I think where the movie gets
particularly dark and so off they go
singing away.
They have to carry them.
So you could say in some sense he's
carried by societal pathology and his
own trouble.
He's carried like a puppet off to
pleasure island.
And so the cricket,
the cricket is again left behind.
He's not the world's best conscience at
this point,
so we don't do it.
Goes off to meet the coachman and the
coachman has already said he's
collecting bad little boys and he's,
he's,
he's got them on the coach.
They're all delinquent types here.
The ticket on the coach was the ace of
spades,
which is what Pinocchio is holding and
he's with this character here called
lamp wick.
That's an interesting name.
So he's the,
he's the thing that Burns in the middle
of a light lamp wick and that's
interesting because it's a play on
Lucifer.
Lucifer means bringer of light.
And so lamp wick is a play on that.
And lamb pork is really a nasty piece of
work.
He's got this false arrogance about him.
He's got this like cynical voice,
really deeply cynical voice and he's
only,
I don't know how old he is supposed to
be in this,
maybe 12 or something like that are 13.
And so he's one of those kids who's,
who's become prematurely cynical.
I'll tell you a story about that.
So I used to live in Montreal.
Um,
I lived in a poor neighborhood and uh,
one day I was out in the back alley
building a fence because I was putting
little fence around my,
my little tiny backyard and there was a
house across the alley down the street a
ways where there is a lot of,
like not good partying.
Lot of bikers are hanging around there.
And I knew there was a little kid that
lived there as well.
Anyways,
I was out there in the back alley,
pounding away on my fence and these
little kids came up and they were
little.
They were like three and four years old.
Hey.
And they spoke a Jew.
All right?
Kinda a really heavily accented
Quebecois French and so on.
My French isn't good so I could hardly
understand them,
but they were what they were watching me
hammer and they got a little closer and
they had one,
one kid who was clearly the leader had a
real scowl on his face.
And so they were watching and I kind of
motioned to one of them that they could
use the hammer and that kid said,
uh,
and I,
I'm gonna mangle this,
but he says you have olay or something
like that.
And what it meant is I'll steal that.
And so I thought,
you know,
and then he came over and he tugged on
it and he wanted me to take it and he
was quite angry and while I was wasn't
gonna let them take it.
And then so,
so I couldn't engage them.
I couldn't get them to play,
you know?
And his buddies were sort of hanging
around behind him and they wouldn't come
and play because he wouldn't.
And so he was hostile right away to me.
And then so the finance piece was laying
out in the La and these little monsters
started running across it,
which I thought was really remarkable,
you know?
But it was terrible at the same time
because they were really little kids
that shouldn't be happening when you're
like three or four if that's happening
at that age.
Things are not good.
And so that kid was already like,
seriously not happy with the world and
you know,
I'd been studying antisocial behavior
for a long time by that point.
And I knew that the kids who are
destined to jail later in their lives,
our kids who are rough and tough when
they're two years old but then don't get
socialized or maybe worse,
they get anti socialized.
Which exactly what happened to this kid.
He'd obviously been ignored and abused.
Certainly no one had ever played with
them in any real way because he,
he wouldn't play.
And it's not good.
If a kid is that little and you can't
get them to play,
something's gone seriously wrong because
there are so playful at that age that
like,
it's like 90 percent of them anyway.
So they were running back and forth on
this fence.
I thought stomping on it,
you know,
and I was right there.
I thought,
well,
I.
First of all,
I thought that was remarkable,
but I also thought it was absolutely
horrifying because,
you know,
in some sense I could see where this kid
was headed and why at that early stage
in his life it's really,
it's not a pleasant thing to behold.
You know,
like there was nothing that could be
done about it.
And that's Kinda what this lamp wick is
like.
He's prematurely cynical.
This kid was already cynical and he was
like four years old.
You know,
most kids don't get cynical till they're
teenagers,
you know?
And then often they don't get completely
cynical and usually they more or less
grow out of it.
But he had,
it happened him much earlier.
So this lamp,
what character he'd already,
he's already decided that he knows
everything that everyone else is.
His opinion is worth nothing and that
there's nothing in culture society that
holds any use utility whatsoever for
someone like him.
Now you can imagine developing that way
if you were raised in a family where
people were generally generally lying to
you and that they randomly treated you
or neglected you and that you couldn't
discern anything about them that was
admirable or positive,
you know,
of course you'd assume that the whole
structure is corrupt and that you had to
take care of yourself and no one else
will not.
Of course not everyone assumes that
under those situations,
I shouldn't say of course,
but it's a.
But it's a logical set of conclusions.
So,
and of course it's proportionate to some
degree to how much abuse you take.
Although there are lots of stories of
people who've been terribly abused as
children who grew up to be,
you know,
kind,
remarkable,
responsible,
thoughtful people who were absolutely
opposed to abuse instead of propagating
it.
There's no direct causal pathway.
Anyways.
Lamp Wick is pretty happy to be on this,
uh,
on this coach way to pleasure island,
which has heard about.
He said,
well,
it's all you can eat.
It's all you can smoke if you don't have
to do any work and you can do anything
you want.
So you might say,
well,
it's too good to be true like the
gingerbread house in the Hansel and
Gretel story.
Right?
And kids are lost.
There's a gingerbread house,
it's a house which is something they
need and it's made out of cookies.
It looks like it's a little bit too good
to be true.
And of course in the house there's a,
the negative part of that,
which is the old witch who wants to eat
children.
And that's a story about what happens to
people if they're offered more than they
should be offered.
So anyways,
lamp wick is firing off a.
He has a little slingshot and he's
firing off pebbles at the horses who are
pulling the carriage.
And that's just kind of the guy that he
is.
So he takes Pinocchio under his wing and
the cricket is down there in the dust.
He's caught back up to the carriage,
but he's,
uh,
he's in,
he's having a rough time at this point.
This is also a story to some degree
about the transition into adolescence.
No,
because adolescence is a time people are
still pretty impulsive and their view is
quite short term and they're more likely
to pursue immediate pleasures and,
and all of that.
And now it can get really out of hand.
So anyways,
they separate from the mainland and go
on a boat.
And so they're off to pleasure island
dark place.
And uh,
the coachman opens the gates and lets
the delinquents into pleasure island and
they basically have a riot.
And this is pleasure island here.
Uh,
it's full of amusement park rides.
And you know,
one of the things that's kind of
interesting about horror movies you,
I'm sure you've noticed this,
is that they're often sat at amusement
parks and clowns are often characters of
horror.
We'll leave the clowns aside for now,
but the amusement park thing that's
pretty interesting.
It's like why in the world would an
amusement park be a place of horror?
And the first question might be,
well have you ever been to an amusement
park because there is something about
them that's really,
they have a dark side,
clear dark side,
and part of it is that people with
nothing better to do or spending money
stupidly and they're being fleeced by
the people who operate the,
the amusement park,
you know,
and they have let's say a
stereotypically dark reputation and
they're moving around all the time,
which is also something that psychopaths
do and all they're doing is moving from
community to community and taking the
money from the rubes fundamentally.
And so the amusement park,
well if you walk through an amusement
park without sort of thing in mind,
maybe that's also coloring your vision
of course,
but it's something that you can see very
immediately.
So there's something about them that's
sort of deeply sad,
but there's also that under,
there's an underlying horror that
characterizes them that it's easy for
horror movie or horror novel writers to
immediately expand upon.
And there's something about it that that
makes sense to people.
So it's too easy.
Maybe that's.
And it's also all short term
gratification.
That's the other thing,
so you spend your money very rapidly and
it's gone.
Yep.
Yes,
exactly.
Well,
that's the impulsive element that the
comment was,
it's a celebration of of meanings
divorced from reality.
Yeah.
That's.
Well,
it's also outside of reality,
right?
That's why it's on an island.
It's a separate universe and it's a
universe where nothing that's happening
is connected to anything outside and
you're spending your hard earned money,
let's say,
but it isn't that much.
It's certainly not an investment.
It's not that much different than
burning it.
What is because of course you get some
pleasure out of it,
but.
But
it isn't going with their.
Everyday is probably not the wisest move
that you could make.
So the animators do a good job of,
of
while I'm presenting the,
what would you call it?
The enforced hedonism.
I guess I would say of a place like
that.
This is a place where you're going to
have fun.
That's what it's for.
So anyways,
lamp wick,
who's got this very arrogant look on his
face and this kind of structure.
It's a.
it's a bravado.
That's what that's called.
It's a false confidence and it's,
it's,
it's the sort of thing that people do
when they're trying to impress upon
others that they're high in the
dominance hierarchy,
but really they're not.
So it's a mimicry of,
of dominance,
but it's something that can,
that can be intimidating.
There's no doubt about it.
Um,
I had a friend,
he,
he didn't come to a good end.
This,
this person who was a real good friend
of mine when I was in junior high and
high school and he was kind of crazy and
uh,
he was tall.
He was about six foot seven and he was
pretty thin and we used to go up to the
bar now and then.
And in many of the bars that we were in
were in,
lived in this little town.
There were bullies and these were guys
and I worked in the bars and I used to
watch these guys and they'd basically,
there was a handful of them in town,
pretty psychopathic types,
and they'd go to the bar and all they do
is sit there and wait for someone to
come in who they could beat up and they
knew who it was as soon as they walked
in.
That's actually why they were at the
bar.
And so they'd wait until someone came in
who didn't look very confident and who
could likely be intimidated by,
by this sort of thing.
And then they'd tell him to come outside
for a fight.
And if they didn't,
well then they of course make fun of
them.
And if they did well,
generally they beat them up.
My friend kind of caught onto this trick
and he started going to bars and every
time that someone like that came near
him,
he'd go outside and fight with them.
And one of the things he observed right
away is that almost inevitably when he
went outside with them,
they'd shake hands and make friends.
So as soon as he,
and it was really remarkable watching
him because he wasn't,
he wasn't a particularly physically
powerful person,
although he was extraordinarily tall,
but he had started to play this game and
he did it for a long time and I don't
remember him ever actually having to
fight.
He just stared them down fundamentally.
So it was very interesting thing to
watch,
but it,
it,
it was an indication to me of exactly
how shallow this kind of bravado
bullying actually is.
But people don't.
People don't find that out because they
won't stand up and it's not surprising,
but
anyways,
they load up on Food Pinocchio's
carrying a Pi and an ice cream cone
simultaneously and then they're off to
have a fight and lamp says something
like,
it's good to punch someone in the nose
sometimes just for the heck of it.
And so Pinocchio adopts this struct and
then they go to the rough house.
And then in the next scene you see this
model home up for destruction.
It's quite an interesting scene.
Symbolically.
See,
in the middle of this house here,
there's a stain glass window that has a
Mandela on it.
We'll see it more clearly in a minute.
And Amanda Mandela is a sacred symbol of
the self.
That's,
that's the union interpretation.
It's a symbol.
It's very difficult to describe,
but it's,
it's a symbol.
Music is a Mandela except it's played
out across time.
So you could say that that thing is the
same as music,
but it's Kinda like a slice of music.
It's,
it's,
it's the same idea.
You know,
sometimes you see those slow motion or
sped up motion videos of a flower
unfolding that's the same.
It's the same idea.
You can imagine that being set to music
and somehow that would make sense.
And the Mandela as like a symbol of the
unfolding of being and,
or the source of meaning or something
like that.
And it's also a symbol of the self.
I'm from the union perspective.
And so there you see it more clearly.
The kids are starting to burn this place
and,
and trash it and they're dragging a
grand piano down the,
down the stairs.
Uh,
the destruction of high culture,
about which they're nothing but cynical
because they don't believe that hard
work and sacrifice can,
can produce something of any value and
they want to bring it down and destroy
it.
And that's partly because
can see this in the story of Cain and
Abel.
Table is hard working and everyone likes
him and he makes the proper sacrifices.
And so his life goes really well.
And that's part of the reason that cain
hates him and he's jealous and
resentful.
But worse than that,
if you're around someone,
if you're not doing very well,
especially if that's your own fault.
If you're not doing very well and you're
around someone who's doing very well,
it's very painful because the mere fact
of there being judges you and so it's
very easy to want to destroy that,
to destroy that ideal so that you don't
have to live with the terrible
consequences of seeing it embodied in
front of you.
And so part of the reason that people
want to tear things down is so that they
don't have anything to contrast
themselves against and to feel bad.
And that's exactly what's happening
here.
The kids are destroying all of this
culture,
roughly speaking because it judges them
the fact that it exists,
judges them.
And I've often thought this about
Michelangelo Statue of David,
which is this heroic.
So David was a shepherd,
obviously it
doesn't sound like much,
but back in those times being a shepherd
was a big deal because there were lions
and you had a slingshot and so like you
got to defend your sheep from lions with
a slingshot.
So you weren't exactly this 19th century
English guy dressed in a,
you know,
fairly blue suit.
You were tough as a bloody well as
someone who would go after lion with a
slingshot.
It's no joke.
Anyways,
the statue is very heroic and you know,
when you look at that,
you think,
well that's the possibility of,
of humankind.
But by the same token,
it's also what you're not.
And so as well as being an ideal,
it's a judge and every ideal is a judge.
So yes.
Yep.
So you're,
you're using that as an example to
illustrate becoming fitter as a result
of not being able to achieve.
Sure.
A status as a result,
success even faster as a result of hard
work,
but in the example of Canaan,
April.
Yeah,
like one was a shepherd and there was a
farmer and the one who knows no one is.
Yes,
that's right.
Yes.
Who was the shepherd?
Was the one who was favorite,
right.
Was that a result of the hard work or
was that a result of good question?
The stories as well.
That's a good question.
Those stories are very,
very complicated and the story is very
ambivalent about whether Kane is not
rewarded because he makes bad sacrifices
are because God's just in a bad mood and
I like that.
If you read the story,
I've read multiple translations of the
story.
When cain comes to God to complain,
God basically tells him,
look,
buddy,
before you go about criticizing the
structure of reality,
you should look to your own
inadequacies.
He says,
Sin Crouches at your door like a
predatory sexually aroused animal,
and you invited it in to have its way
with you.
And something has emerged as a
consequence.
So be bothered me about my creation
before you look to yourself.
So there's a very strong hint that the
reason that God has not favored cane
sacrifices because they weren't a
particularly good quality,
so but that,
but it is ambivalent in the story and
there is the shepherd versus farmer
Motif as well and of course that Motif
runs through the whole entire corpus of
stories to some degree,
especially the shepherd motif.
So it's only about a paragraph long,
that whole story and it packs all that
into that tiny little amount of space.
But the,
the idea that cain kills able to get rid
of his ideal and also to punish God.
Roughly speaking.
It's a brilliant story.
I mean these guys who go around shooting
up high schools are shooting up high
schools in particular,
but there are definitely out for revenge
and what their revenging themselves
against or to who is not exactly clear
anyways.
So these kids are just tearing down this
model.
Home tearing Western civilization I
suppose is another way of looking at or
just tearing down civilization period.
And Pinocchio Pinocchio's having a
pretty good time.
He's got his ax and he's looking a
little malevolent level in there.
And,
and happy to be destroying things,
which is of course a pretty simple thing
to do.
So there's that image that I told you
about the Mandela that's a flower in
this image.
And so what happens is that,
uh,
I think it's lamp life throws a brick
through it.
And so what that means symbolically,
this the self is a symbol of your
potential among very many other things.
But by engaging in this sort of
impulsive,
destructive activity,
lamp,
Wick,
and Pinocchio,
or making it impossible for them to
further their development.
And they're doing that to some degree
consciously,
you know,
they basically say to hell with it and
toss a brick through this highest ideal,
the thing through which light shines.
So also that hearkens back to the,
to the stars.
Well,
so anyways,
the coachman is paying attention to all
this and he's actually pretty happy
about the fact that these boys are so
involved in their stupid amusements
that,
um,
that they're not paying any attention to
what's actually going on.
And he calls these people out of the
darkness,
these creatures out of the darkness.
So you get these black,
you can hardly see them there,
but there are black cloak figures with
glowing eyes and there are shutting the
door of the,
of the amusement park.
That's very interesting.
It's an extraordinarily interesting
happening.
It's like,
okay.
So all of a sudden the amusement park is
associate.
We already know that the coachman is up
to no good,
but now he's got these minions that are
faceless and in some sense they're
clearly creatures of the night and
they're up to no good.
And so you have the sense that,
that the boys are being offered bread,
bread and circuses,
roughly speaking,
but there's something,
there's a real reason for it.
There's a manipulative reason for it.
They're being enticed into a trap and
uh,
the doors are closed and these
underground beings are involved in the
plot.
And,
and obviously the coach went understands
this perfectly well.
And so one of the ways to understand
this is to think about what totalitarian
states have to offer their populous and
what they offered them.
And this happened particularly as Rome
declined.
Let's say that's where the term bread
and circuses originally came from,
is that as the situation regenerates,
then people have to be offered stupid
amusements more and more frequently in
order to for them to ignore what's
actually going on in the background and
you know a war can be that kind of
stupid amusement.
Anyways.
The next later that night,
the entire place is completely
devastated and all we see as the
wreckage of everything that was there
before and again in the cricket has got
separated from Pinocchio and so he's
trying to find a mentor.
Pinocchio ends up in this.
This bar that's shaped like an eight
ball,
eight ball is kind of the random ball in
in pool and anyways,
he's inside
the eight ball and he's shooting pool
with with lamp wick and that's just
another indication of wasting his time.
Basically.
You can see in the forefront there,
there's some cards for gambling and so
he's engaged in these sort of a,
you might say pointless.
He don't want it pursuits and he's a
enticing Pinocchio along the same route
and so he teaches him to smoke first.
That doesn't go very well,
so Pinocchio takes a huge drag on a
cigar and it just about kills them and
uh,
wouldn't amp quick asks him how he likes
it.
He shakes his head and says,
you know,
that it's really,
it was really quite good,
but he's so sick that he can hardly
stand up and he's hallucinating double
balls on the pool table and then the
cricket shows up and stands on the eight
ball and kind of gives one of those
declamatory speeches again,
you know,
because he still hasn't quite figured
out that standing up proud and spouting
off the rules isn't exactly the right
way for the conscience to behave.
And a lamp wick picks him up by the
scruff of the neck,
roughly speaking.
First of all,
I asked who he is.
So obviously he's divorced from his own
conscience and then makes fun of
Pinocchio for paying attention to this
little bug.
And that's kind of a nice indication of
what happens in adolescence,
you know,
because of course,
as children move away from their parents
and into their groups,
especially when the groups are
misbehaving,
often what happens is that the other
members of the group will torture a
person who isn't willing to try
something dangerous or foolish by making
fun of the fact that they're too
attached to their conscience.
And there's a positive element to that
because you shouldn't take some risks
when you're a teenager and also later in
life.
And so if you won't take any risks,
there's actually something wrong with
you.
But there's a negative element in that.
Well,
you know,
teenagers do all sorts of stupid things
and perhaps it's amazing that we all
lived through it actually,
as far as I'm concerned.
Some people take extraordinary risks,
extraordinary risks,
and they don't make it through at all.
Or they end up in the permanently
antisocial population.
And then they're,
you know,
basically career criminals,
five percent of the criminals commit 95
percent of the crimes.
It's another prieto distribution.
So anyways,
lamp isn't going to listen to Pinocchio
or to the cricket,
he laughs out of him with his kind of
breaking laugh,
which is some foreshadowing and uh,
the cricket gets all upset,
puts his coat on backwards and ends up
dumped down a pool table hole and uh,
otherwise abused.
And so he stomps on out of their details
Pinocchio that he can take care of
himself and he stomps on out of there.
And so Pinocchio is left without the
guidance of conscience and the cricket
is trying to figure out how to get off
pleasure island,
but he goes through the gates and he
sees what's actually going on.
And what's going on is that the coach
when has this like slave boat down in
the bowels of the island and he's got
all these,
these black suited minions with glowing
eyes working for him and they're
rounding up what looked like donkeys.
And so there are beasts of burden,
right?
And so there's an idea here that if you
produce,
if you pursue impulsive pleasure to the
detriment of the development of your
character,
you're going to end up a beast of
burden.
You're going to end up a slave to a
tyrant and that's exactly right,
and so anyways,
other cricket doesn't.
You can see one of those black suited
horrors here,
hauling donkeys out of this crate and
one of them has a hat on and they looked
very sad and they're in different crates
and one of them says,
sold to the salt mines and one says sold
to the circus,
and so they're shipped off to be to be
slaves roughly speaking,
and they look very sad and then one of
them gets hauled out of a crate and he's
still got a hat.
He has a hat on and a sweater and he can
still talk.
He's a boy.
It turns out that's been half
transformed into a jackass,
a jackass prior to being enslaved.
And so that's.
That's another thing that's quite
interesting about the story.
You know,
it,
it.
It also makes the case that if you
replace your voice with stupid brain,
that the probability that you're going
to become enslaved by a tyrant is
extraordinarily high and I always can't
help but think about idiot idiot logs in
that manner.
No Solzhenitsyn wrote about the radical
left ideologues that got thrown in the
Gulag archipelago,
you know,
so they were part party stalwarts.
This happened to a lot of people,
true believers who are vacuumed up by
this machine and thrown in,
thrown into the Gulag anyways.
And he said that those people suffered
in some ways more than everyone else
because what did he say?
They were bit by the beloved hand that
fed them.
And so the first while when they were in
the camps,
Solzhenitsyn really didn't know what to
do with people like that because on the
one hand while they were in the camps
and wasn't that awful and they'd been
torn away from their families and you
know,
stripped of all their identity and their
status and so that's pretty rough.
But on other hand they were writing
letters,
protesting their innocence and assuming
that everyone else in the camp was
guilty but they were innocent and they
were still strident believers in the
communist process.
And so you know,
it was a conundrum here,
they are being terribly punished,
but by the same token there are also the
perpetrators have their own device,
so how do you deal with them?
And they used to play comrades,
he said they used to play comrades with
people like that and invite them into an
ideological discussion about the camp
situation and the situation in the
country as a whole and let them rattle
out their ideological justification for
everything that had happened in trying
to make them parody themselves.
Roughly speaking,
it was a rough game and units and also
concluded that
there is no helping someone like that
when they were still ensconced inside
that brain ideology.
You can predict everything they were
going to say.
It's like someone had a crank,
you could just crank it and out would
come the proper ideological formulas.
But then he realized that as soon as
they,
let's call it,
repented of that and started to realize
they're their own role in it or the era
of the system,
then he would start communicating with
them.
You know,
as if they were people who who you could
communicate with.
Yeah.
So that was very interesting as far as
I'm concerned.
Anyways,
this kid is still a little bit human.
He starts to cry for his mom and the
coachman basically throws them back into
the crate and says that he's not ready
yet.
And the reason for that is that he could
still,
he still had the power of independent
speech.
You remember right at the beginning of
the movie when the mouth was painted on
Pinocchio,
we saw that mask that was really glaring
at the process and I said that character
recurs continually throughout the movie
and is a good example of that because
the coach is the enemy of anything that
has its own voice.
So he's the anti Japan.
Oh,
that's a good way of thinking about it.
He's the tyrannical aspect of the
culture.
But as in so far as one of these,
mostly donkey's,
mostly Jack assets can still talk then
they're not completely fit for slavery.
And you remember,
this movie was also being made at about
the same time that,
um,
the Nazi transformation of Germany was
taking place.
And so all these terrible underground
things,
you know,
this,
this process whereby people were being
reduced to two ideological slave say and
in this terrible process that was all
playing out in Europe in a very big way.
And it's not like people weren't aware
of that,
you know,
it was in there.
So
anyways,
the donkey's,
the jackasses that can still talk,
her crying and complaining and repenting
and the coachman turns into a full Kyron
again and cracks the whip,
if I remember correctly,
and says,
you've had your fun and now you're going
to pay for it.
So the cricket gets word of all this.
He gets wind of it.
He starts to understand what's happened
is that all these bad kids were enticed
out onto this island so that they could
be enslaved.
And he's really taken aback by that to
say the least,
but he realizes what's going on.
So He runs back to find Pinocchio.
And then the scene switches back to the
eight ball bar where I'm lamp wick is
drinking beer and complaining about what
the conscience said,
you know,
because he's kind of guilty and ashamed,
but he won't admit it because he doesn't
admit anything.
He knows everything.
He's not going to admit anything about
himself that isn't perfect.
He's a real totalitarian training and he
drinks this beer and he's laughing about
the conscience and putting them down.
And then he says,
well,
what?
What is,
what does he say?
Exactly?
What does he think?
I am a jackass or something like that.
Maybe that's not the words.
Exactly.
And then he grows these,
these ears from Pinocchio,
sees that and immediately takes a look
at the beer and stops drinking it.
And then lamp,
quick transforms one more time.
And his face turns into the face of a
donkey.
And he's laughing still.
And then his,
his hands.
Oh yes.
He laughs suddenly starts to bray like
a,
like a jackass.
And he's horrified by that.
And then Pinocchio laughs and the brain
comes out as well.
And so now they're absolutely horrified
and lamp luck actually figures out
what's going on.
He figures out that he's been tricked
and that he's transforming and he's
completely horrified by it.
He becomes conscious of what's happening
to them.
And there's one particularly I would
say,
dramatic scene where his hands have
transformed in hooves and he's kicking
and,
and a leaping around the room and panic
and he comes up to a mirror and sees
himself as a Jack Ass.
And then he turns around and breaks the
mirror.
And so,
you know,
he's self conscious for a moment.
Then he destroys his capacity for self
consciousness that he transforms
entirely into a jackass.
He's farther down the road than
Pinocchio and he comes crawling to
Pinocchio to save him and asks that the
conscience comes back so that he can get
out of this.
But of course it's a bit too late.
And so then UN occhio grows jackass ears
and he's absolutely terrified by it as
well.
He knows what's coming and the cricut
comes back and,
and guides them off.
Pleasure island.
And so then they end up on a cliff
because this is an island after all,
and they have to jump into the unknown,
right out of this impulsive adolescent,
he dominic playground into the unknown.
And that's how they escape.
So that's the first time that Pinocchio
has to leave,
that,
that this is the first scene where he
has to jump into the water to make a
clean break from something pathological.
So tyranny,
you see this echoed you see echoes of
this in the story of Moses leading his
people from,
from Egypt.
Because Moses is a master of water,
right?
If he hits this rock with a stick and
water comes out of it and he's floating
on water when he's an infant and he
parts the Red Sea.
And so he's a master of water and
transformation.
And the Pharaoh is in the Pharaoh's
kingdom,
is represented as a desert stone,
roughly speaking.
And so the idea there is that,
well,
the kingdom is solid ground,
but it can be a tyranny.
And the water is chaos,
but it can be the thing that you have to
leap into to free yourself from the
tyranny.
It's not like in the Moses story that
that comes easy,
right?
Because the the Hebrews leave Israel
with or leave Egypt,
which is a terrible tyranny and you
think,
well that's good.
They've escaped from the tyranny,
but that isn't what happens.
They escaped
from the tyranny of the actually end up
somewhere,
arguably worse because they're wandering
around in the desert for 40 years.
And that's.
It's a brilliant element of that story
because it states clearly that when you
go from a bad place to a better place,
you go to a worst place first and that's
a great.
It's a great thing to know because it
also tells you why you might be
unwilling to take the next step.
You know you're aiming up,
but in order to aim up,
you have to let go of something you
already have and then that'll put you
into a state of chaos.
And unless you're willing to undergo
that intermediary state of chaos and you
might not recover from it,
you're not going to get to the next,
you're not going to get to the next
level.
So.
So that's rough.
Well,
so Pinocchio,
he decides that chaos is better than
tyranny and guided by his conscience
jumps into the water and then we don't
see anything happening in the water in
this particular scene,
they come back to shore,
all half drowned and an exhausted by
their adventure and they go back home.
And I think maybe we'll take a break
now.
Let's see.
This is a good time to take a break.
One 30.
Perfect.
So let's break for 15 minutes.
Okay.
Alright.
So Carl Jung talked about this
phenomena.
He cried phenomenon.
He
described as a retrogressive restoration
of the persona.
And so it's a complicated idea,
but basically what it means is that
sometimes you take a leap forward and
you learn some things,
but you can't catalyze a new identity.
So you try to go back and hide in your
old identity and that actually doesn't
work because while things have changed
and you've learned something and that
isn't who you are anymore and so it's
like you have to cut part parts of
yourself off in a destructive manner to
fit back into the person that you were.
Now What happens here is that Pinocchio
escapes from this tyrannical situation
and undergoes this descend into chaos,
but he tries to go back home.
He tries to go back to what he was and
he can't do that anymore as far there
isn't at home anymore.
And so.
So when he goes home,
he finds that there's no home there.
Now this happens to people sometimes in
soft and a shock to them.
So one of the things I've noticed about
Peter Pan type,
I'm going to speak about men here
because I've observed it more in men,
is that they often stay under the thumb
of their father and you think,
well why would someone do that?
Because it means they're subject to the
tyrannical judgment of their father.
They're always concerned about what
their father would think or whether
their father approves of it and so
forth,
and you think,
well,
that's got to be an unpleasant place to
be.
Why would you do that?
One of the things that I've suggested to
my clients and to other people sometimes
is that here's a weird little exercise
that you can undertake.
A little thought experiment.
So you have your parents and of course
your parents have friends who are about
their age and maybe some of them are
people you only know peripherally.
And I might ask you,
well,
do you care more about what your parents
think than you care about what these
peripheral people who know your parents
think?
And then the answer to that is,
well,
of course.
And then the question that arises out of
that is why.
I mean,
for someone else,
your parents are the peripheral people
and their parents are central.
Like,
why is it logical that your parents make
opinion makes any difference to you than
the appearance,
than the,
uh,
the opinion of some randomly selected
people who are approximately that age.
Why is it the case that you would
consider that they would know more than
someone else?
I mean,
I know they know you better and fair
enough,
but that that's not the point.
And then another point there is that to
the degree that your parents opinion
about you matters more than some
randomly selected,
people have approximately the same age.
Young would say,
well,
you haven't exactly separated out the
God the image from your parents and so
you're still under that,
that combination.
It's like a complicated thing to talk
about,
but think about the Harry Potter series.
Harry has two sets of parents,
right?
He's got the dearsley parents and then
he's got these like magical parents that
sort of float behind and he should know
the difference between them.
They shouldn't be one in the same.
They're not for him and it's like,
well,
you have your parents and you have
nature and culture as parents and you
shouldn't be thinking that your parents
are nature and culture as well.
It shouldn't have final dominion over
you means that you're not an individual
yet.
If that's the case.
Freud said,
for example,
that,
no,
no one could be a man in les.
His father had died and young said,
yes,
but that death can take place
symbolically.
Okay,
so there's that part of the idea,
and then another part of the idea is one
of the times in your life when you
actually realize that you're an
individual is when you'll go and ask
your parents something and you'll
realize they actually don't know any
more about what you should do.
Then you do,
and that sucks and that's partly why
people are often willing to maintain a
tyrant slave relationship with their
father.
It's like on the one hand,
you have to be inferior in a
relationship like that.
You know you've always got the judge
watching you,
but another hand,
there's always someone who knows what to
do.
There's always standing between you and
the unknown that you can go ask,
what should I do?
Well,
at some point you'll realize that the
reason you can't ask that anymore is
because they actually don't know any
more than you do,
and then that's a pain like that.
That is a symbolic death.
Now it's also when you establish a more
individual relationship with your
parents,
it's at that point that you could
conceivably start taking care of them
instead of the reverse and that's a time
that should come,
but you have to let that image of
perfection go and that exposes you.
Well,
that's what happens here.
You know,
Pinocchio goes home and he wants things
to be the way they were and he wants to
stay under the careful care of the
benevolent father,
but that's no longer possible.
He's past that point and that's why the
father has disappeared and so Japan has
gone off to look for Pinocchio because
he also needs the sun.
But,
but in any case,
the house is abandoned and so then we
see inside the house that everything's
covered with cobwebs and everything's
gone in Pinocchio and the cricket sit on
the steps and they're very concerned.
First of all,
they wonder where he went.
So they're actually concerned that he's
gone,
but they also don't know what to do
because there's just no going home.
And so,
you know,
that's also the case that once you hit a
certain point in your development,
well it's the same thing we already
talked about the answers that you're
looking for are not going to be found in
your parents house.
It's as simple as that.
Now you could artificially maintain your
dependency,
but you know,
if you do that for too long,
things get pretty ugly.
So you get pretty stale and,
and you know,
you're like bread that's been on the
shelf for too long.
So now they're wondering what to do and
where he could be.
And then there's something very strange
happens.
The star shows up again and it turns
into a dove and the dove flies down and
puts a piece of paper bathed in light
with gold writing on it in front of the
cricket and the puppet.
So what in the world's going on there?
Well,
we know what the star is.
We've seen it multiple times,
right?
It's also the place that the blue fairy
came from,
but it's this transcendent place.
It's this place that occurs sort of as
the ultimate ideal.
And this time it delivers a message.
So what's happening here is
Pinocchio is fundamentally oriented by
the wish that his father made so long
ago,
right?
And the wish was that he would become a
fully functioning individual.
And so that's that transcendent place.
And young would say when you,
when you orient your vision,
different things appear to you in the
world.
So and I mean this literally so because
you can't see everything,
your vision calculates what's necessary.
Your brain calculates what's necessary
for you to see so that you get to the
point that you're aiming at.
And I don't mean that metaphorically.
I mean it literally.
Things that aren't relevant to what
you're seeking won't.
You won't see them unless they get in
your way and they have to.
They have to really block your pathway
before there'll be literally visible.
So you orient yourself towards something
and that makes some things visible that
wouldn't be visible.
It makes other things invisible that you
might've seen.
And so when you change your orientation,
what manifests itself in the world also
changes.
Know Pinocchio is in despair here.
And he asks himself,
where could my father have gone?
And so the question is,
what exactly is he asking under those
circumstances?
And what he's asking is something like,
I had a structure that was orienting me
properly in relationship to the world
and as far as it was embodied in my
actual father,
it's now gone.
Is there any possibility that I can find
that again?
And that is what you want.
You see like if you're in a chaotic
circumstance,
maybe you've escaped,
let's say from a bad relationship or
something like that and you're out of
it,
but now you don't know what to do.
What you're hoping is that you can get
your life back together,
right?
That you can put the pieces that have
fallen apart,
back together,
and so you're automatically going to
generate a fantasy about producing
another.
Let's call it stable state.
You're going to be looking for this
spirit that would enable that stable
state to be generated because really
what it is,
and in some senses,
your new personality,
you're in chaos.
You have to become something new in
order to get out of chaos.
And so you're hoping for that,
you're hoping that you'll see it,
and so
that's going to make certain things
visible to you.
That's the.
That's the proper way of thinking about
it.
You know,
when you get curious about something and
maybe you're curious about something and
you walk into a bookstore,
that curiosity is going to guide you to
a certain set of books.
The fact that you have the question in
mind is going to open your eyes to
certain kinds of possibilities.
And so if your goal is to reestablish
your union with the positive father,
let's say,
then certain things are going to appear
in other things aren't.
And that's really what this represents.
A transcendent star is the goal,
which is this developmental process.
It's capable of,
let's say,
delivering a message to you.
Some sense that's what's happening when
you're thinking,
you know,
because you have a problem you want to
solve,
you have somewhere you want to go with
your thoughts,
and as a consequence of that information
reveals itself to you.
In the interior landscape.
It's a very strange thing.
In some sense,
it feels as if you're producing the
thoughts,
but it could equally be said that you're
watching the thoughts revealed
themselves and which of those is the
more accurate description is by no means
obvious.
You can certainly have thoughts that
surprise you,
which is very strange.
It's like they're your thoughts.
How in the world can they surprise you,
but they do so it's like you didn't know
them before you thought them up,
but then the question is,
well,
where did they come from?
If you didn't know them before you
thought them up,
they sort of spring out of the void.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Anyways,
this is a holy ghost symbol.
This dove as well,
so that puts some Christian imagery in
here.
Again,
you could think of it as a manifestation
of the spirit of transformation.
That's another way of looking at it.
Anyways.
It's the conscience that interprets the
letter,
so it's sort of figuring out what the
next thing should be,
and weirdly enough,
what the letter says is that Japan was
out looking for Pinocchio and he got
swallowed by a whale,
which makes very little sense to put it
bluntly.
Japan,
I went to search for Pinocchio and now
he's at the bottom of the sea in a giant
whale and
we bright over that tremendous gap in
logic and follow the story nonetheless.
Okay,
so what's the idea here?
The idea is that if you're.
If you fall into a chaotic state and
everything falls apart,
there's the possibility that
things can come back together,
including what you've just learned in a
new state,
and so you can conceptualize that
symbolically as the existence of the
dead father at the bottom of the,
of the chaotic landscape.
That's.
That's the proper way as far as I can
tell,
to think about it.
It's like there's something down there
that's capable of reforming and
reemerging.
That's that incorporates the previous
state,
but that takes it farther and you're not
going to find that unless you descend
into this chaotic place where it feels
like all order is gone while you
generate order.
It's going to be akin to the order that
you had before,
but there's going to be something new
about it as well,
so it's down to the bottom of the
chaotic state to bring up what you're
missing and that's one level of
analysis.
Another level of analysis you think is,
well,
that's also what you're doing.
That's what you should be doing in
principle when you're going to
university,
you know you're.
You come to university in roughly the
same status.
Pinocchio,
you know you're a bit of a puppet and
you're kind of a jackass and what the
hell do you know?
And it's chaotic because you haven't
found your place in the world properly.
And I don't mean merely for career.
Not that that's not relevant because it
is,
but it's more than that.
It's because you're a historical
creature because you are a product of
history.
Unless you are inculturated properly,
which means you understand your past and
in the sense that the humanities can
allow for that,
then
you haven't been able to incorporate the
wisdom of your ancestors into your day
to day pursuits and that's gonna make
you weak.
That's the idea anyways,
and so when you come to university,
this is what university is for it so
that you can go into the chaos and you
can pull something out of it that's
truly a value and you can incorporate
that in your own personality and that
makes you much,
much stronger,
like literally stronger.
Not more educated but not.
It's not like you know more facts.
It's that you literally are a better
person and better means you can do far
more things.
You can articulate your.
That's.
That's something that's of crucial
importance is that you can articulate
yourself properly,
which is more useful than anything else
you could possibly manage.
Like if you guys come out of university
capable of making coherent arguments and
using language properly,
you're so powerful that it's ridiculous.
You,
you always,
you can lay out a strategy and pursue it
successfully and maybe the strategy is
actually oriented towards something
good.
Something that will actually work,
work for you and work for other people
as well,
and I don't really understand why people
aren't taught,
told this when they come to university,
is that your goal is to make yourself as
articulate in writing and thinking and
speaking as you possibly can because
that opens the door to everything that
you'll want to do in the future.
No matter what it is,
the more articulate person always rises
always because they lay out strategies
more effectively.
They they lay out the reasons for doing
something or for not doing something
more particularly.
They convinced people and properly so
that they can grapple with potentials
that lies ahead effectively and they can
defend themselves when they're
challenged.
And so all of that is going into the
past,
into the chaos of the past.
You could even say and pulling up the
spirit that inhabits that from the
bottom and uniting with it.
And if you don't do that well,
you're defenseless.
In the case of in the face of the
tragedy of life and and then,
then that's not so good because if
you're defenseless in the face of the
tragedy of life,
then you get way more hurt than you
would otherwise get and some of the
people around you and then the
probability that you're going to be
resentful and about that is really high
because no one likes to fail continually
and then you get bitter and resentful
and then once you're bitter and
resentful,
well being,
being vengeful and mean is the next
step.
It doesn't take much of a transformation
to move you from place to the next.
So now Pinocchio has to face the thing
that he's afraid of most and that's a
complicated
idea as well.
So you had this phrase that he liked,
that he took from the alchemists,
which was in stir wiliness infinite
tour,
and what it meant was what you most want
to find will be found where you least
want to look.
There's this old story.
It's from King Arthur.
King Arthur has these nights,
right?
They all sit around a round table,
which means they're roughly equal.
That's what the round table means and
they're off to find the holy grail and
the holy grail is the most valuable
object that that's what it means.
So they're off to find the most valuable
thing,
but they don't know what it is and they
don't know where it is,
but they know that there's a most
valuable thing.
So in some sense it's akin to them
orienting themselves by the star and
they don't know where to look.
And so what they decide is they have the
castle.
It's the middle of a forest.
And so each night decides to start
looking for the holy grail by entering
the forest at the point that looks
darkest to him.
And so what's the idea there?
Well,
imagine there are things that come easy
to you and that you're fond of pursuing
and that you're happy about pursuing.
So you found those and pursued them and
you've mastered them.
So you know all that,
but then there's another place that you
don't want to go.
And so you haven't gone there and you
haven't mastered it and you're a very
small in comparison to it because you
haven't mastered it and so it has this
monstrous aspect and but it has if what
you're working where you,
if what you're doing isn't working,
it's where you haven't gone that you
need to go.
And so I can give you another example of
this.
So let's say you're an agreeable person
and so you don't like conflict and you
won't stand up for yourself and you
regard anger and the proclivity to
provoke and to engage in conflict as
something that's positively terrible.
It's not only that you're not good at
it,
it's actually that it's wrong.
So that's where you have to go.
If you're going to learn how to stand up
for yourself and imagine that you're
afraid,
maybe you have something like Agora
Phobia.
And so there's a whole bunch of things
that you're afraid of and you don't want
to go there.
But if you want to put yourself
together,
then that's exactly where you have to
go.
And so it's frequently the case that
what you want to find is to be found
were you least want to find it,
and that idea is echoed in the
prominent stories of dragons and gold.
It's exactly the same idea,
is that the dragon is this terrible
thing.
It's this terrible predatory thing that
lives forever and is very,
very wise.
It lives underground and it'll kill you,
it'll burn you up in a second,
but it hoards gold,
and so you have to go there into the
dragon's layer if you're going to get
the gold,
and that's a representation of people's
paradoxical relationship with reality.
It's like you have to go out there and
confronted in order to incorporate what
it has to offer to you,
but the probability that that's going to
be intensely dangerous and push you
right to the limit.
First of all,
those are actually the same thing.
If it didn't push you to the limit,
you wouldn't gain anything valuable from
it.
So you don't get one without the other.
You don't get the gold without the
dragon.
That's a very strange,
very,
very strange idea,
but it seems to be accurate,
so all of that's lurking underneath this
in this imagery of the whale,
the thing that's at the bottom of now,
the whale,
you can think of the story of Jonah.
What happens with Jonah is that roughly
speaking,
he's a prophet and God tells him that he
has to,
if I remember correctly,
God tells them in the house to go to
this city and straighten it out because
it's.
It's veered off the path and it's.
It's heading towards doom and Jonah
thinks I'm not going to that city to
tell those people anything like that
because they're not going to be very
happy with me just showing up there and
telling them everything they're doing
wrong and so he hops on a boat and tries
to get out of there and then God
conjures up this huge storm and the boat
is about to be swamped and the sailors,
they're worried about making the boat
lighter.
Something like that.
They all draw a lot to see who gets
tossed overboard and Jonah admits that
it's actually his fault because God's
upset with him because he got this
direct command to go straighten out the
city and he ran off and so the sailors
throat,
they're not happy about this,
but they throw Jonah overboard and the
CS and great fish comes up and swallows
them.
Then he's down in the fish for three
days and it throws up on the dry land
and then he's learned his lesson by that
time and he goes off to have this,
pursue the proper destiny to pursue his
proper destiny.
So that's echoed in this story as well,
that
if you don't follow the pathway that
you're supposed to follow,
that this cs will become stormy for you
and something will come up and pull you
down and you'll be in a terrible place
for some length of time until you learn
your lesson and if you're lucky,
you'll get spit back up on shore and
then you can go do what you should do.
Well,
I mean that's not less than that.
Anybody needs to have interpreted.
I think everybody understands that.
Anyways,
the Cricket Tells Pinocchio what he has
to do and then something of paradoxical
happens.
Pinocchio decides he's going to go do
this,
and then the cricket is got this weird
paradoxical response to that.
On the one hand,
he's he sort pulling Pinocchio back
saying,
look,
you know,
this is foolhardy that you're going to
go all the way down to the ocean.
You're going to confront this terrible
whale.
This is really,
really dangerous,
but at the same time when Pinocchio is
on the edge of the cliff,
the cricket helps him tie his tail
around a rock and he.
He holds his finger in place so that
Pinocchio can tie the knot.
It's like the conscience is conflicted
about this.
It's really dangerous and foolhardy,
but it's also necessary and so he plays
this dual role,
but Pinocchio is leading at this point,
so into the ocean.
He goes,
I guess partly what this means is that
if you're not oriented properly in the
world,
you should take your doubts and you
should take your doubts and the chaos
that you're involved in.
Seriously,
he should face it and think it through.
You should go into it as far as you can
go into it because maybe you'll find
something at the bottom of it.
I mean,
the alternative is to pretend that it
doesn't exist,
so then Pinocchio is at the bottom of
the water.
He can.
He can actually breathe down there.
It turns out so you could think that
he's gone into the unknown.
He's outside of dry land.
He's in the unconscious.
All of those things are true and you
might think,
well,
why would it be the world outside of
what's known and the unconscious at the
same time,
this weird intermingling of those two
things and as far as I can tell,
that's because
when you're in chaos and you don't know
what's going on,
then you start imagining what might be
going on and that imagination is partly
the world as it might be,
but it's also partly the structure of
your unconscious mind,
which is producing the fantasies.
And so when you're truly in chaos,
then the distinction between your
fantasies and reality isn't clear.
That's actually part of what constitutes
the chaos.
So imagine this,
so you're in a relationship and the
person betrays you and you knew who they
were,
at least you thought you did before that
moment,
but now you're looking at them and you
don't know who they are and you don't
know what the past was and you don't
know what the present is and you don't
know what the future's going to be.
All of that's been thrown up into the
air in a major way that's traumatic.
So much has fallen apart that it's
traumatic.
So what do you start to do?
You start to imagine what might be the
situation.
Well then the reality,
the reality is your imagination and the
reality.
At the same time,
they're not pulled apart at all.
You cannot distinguish between them.
And so
it was a young an idea.
I could say that's the snitch that Harry
Potter is chasing.
By the way,
I know what.
That's a terrible leap,
but that is what it is.
It's that weird intermingling potential
in reality that that can manifest itself
as the world if you pursue it.
It's roughly that.
So Pinocchio is in this situation that's
half fantasy and half reality in this
chaotic state,
and he had us to go down to find the
thing that he leased,
wants to find,
and he's hoping that it.
He's got this intuition that in facing
that thing,
that chaos,
that that life really is that chaos,
that he's going to find his father and
reunite with them.
So you could also say that in some sense
it's a decision of faith,
I suppose because
you might ask yourself,
well,
why bother confronted chaos?
Chaos is the ultimate reality.
Then what the hell uses they're in
facing it because it's just going to
reveal itself as the ultimate reality
and drown you,
but the myths always say the same thing.
They say,
no,
no.
If you confront what's really disturbing
you,
if you really confronted you do it
voluntarily,
you're going to find order in it
eventually,
or at least that's the only way you're
going to find order.
Now.
It's not like these stories are
optimistic and it's not as if they give
you a sure guide to success.
That's the other thing.
It's not like they're unerringly
accurate because you can be subsumed by
chaos that so total that even if you
face it,
you're not going to prevail.
I mean,
that's why people die.
That's one way of looking at it anyways,
but the mythology basically says this is
your best bet.
If there is a process that's going to
work,
this is it,
and so,
and then you might think,
well,
the better you do it,
the better the chance of success,
or the more consistently you do it,
the better the chances of success are.
And I think that that's a perfectly
reasonable way of looking at it.
Okay,
so anyways,
Pinocchio's down at the bottom of the
ocean and every time he says he's trying
to find out where monster is
and they ask questions to the fish that
are down there,
but every time they mentioned monster,
who's name all the fish disappeared.
It's like Voldemort,
right?
He's the guy whose name you cannot say
and monster we is precisely that.
It's the thing that frightens everyone.
And so asking questions down there isn't
helping very much.
So Pinocchio,
what he does is he's calling for his
father and he keeps going deeper and
deeper into the depths and we're in a
scene.
There's a scene where
the darkness of the ocean turns into an
even more profound darkness and that's
what okay,
well disappears into.
And then we see monster always in this
sort of foggy representation,
this huge thing that lies very much at
the bottom and there's no life or
anything around him except I think these
are macro,
but maybe their tuna,
their animated anyway,
so it doesn't matter,
but there's no life down there.
He is so far down at the bottom of the
ocean that there's nothing that's alive
down there.
So.
And then we go inside the which is of
course absurd and we see that the whale
has eaten a boat at some point in the
past.
This is one whopping whale and Japan is
sitting with the kitten of all things.
He's also got that little goldfish bowl
full of goldfish with them too,
which is quite the feat.
Anyways,
he's sitting there and he's.
He knows that he's trapped in the belly
of the whale to and in that he can't get
out.
And so that's an interesting issue.
It's because not only is Pinocchio
lacking his father,
which isn't a good thing,
but the farther is lacking the sun and
there is some indication that the father
can't get out of the whale without the
sun and so it's like the possibility for
order is down there in this chaotic
state,
but unless there's an active agent to go
seek it out,
it can't pull itself.
It's not animated enough to get out by
itself,
you know?
And you could say,
well there's wisdom in the libraries,
but it's not going to like without you
going in there and gathering it and
embodying it.
All it does is sit there and potential.
And in all of that,
in all of that implicit form,
now it's a good way of thinking about
it.
So anyways,
Jupiter was pretty feeling pretty
hopeless because he can't figure out any
way of getting out of the whale and he's
also starving.
He's starving in the belly of the whale.
And
here's a way of thinking about that
Japan is a good guy,
but he's old and that being his way of
doing things is no longer fruitful.
That's why you starving.
And it's especially not fruitful because
he's missing his son.
He's missing the active element that the
child represents,
say the playful and transformative
element that the child represents.
And so if you get stuck doing something
the same old way,
at some point,
it's no longer going to work.
Even if it was good at some point it has
to be updated and it's updated by,
let's call it the spirit of youth or the
spirit of attention or the spirit of
play,
something like that.
The willingness to break boundaries and
take risks in Japan,
eto is very,
very skilled,
but,
but he doesn't have that.
That symbolized by the loss of his son.
That's why he was looking for his son
too.
We need them and so they're in despair
down there trying to fish and not
getting anything.
And so
monster wakes up.
Mackerel happens to swim by and monster
wakes up.
And so then he started,
I think there two now actually,
they look like tune into me and so
monster wakes up and he opens his mouth
and a bunch of water starts to come in
and so.
And then you see Pinocchio with the
fish.
Now
there's very intense implicit Christian
symbolism in this part of the film.
And I'm going to lay it out point by
point.
So you may remember and perhaps you
don't.
Perhaps you don't know that one of the
symbols for Christ is a fish it thesis.
Right?
And that's a play on the Greek
representation,
Christ's name.
But there's more to it than that because
all of Christ's followers are fishermen
and he performs a bunch of miracles with
fish and fish are strange things because
while you can pull them up out of the
depths,
that's part of it.
And so there are things that can be
pulled out of the depth and you could
say that
it's going to be very difficult for me
to take this apart.
But you could say in some sense that
Christ is a matter of fish.
A fish is something that you can dine
on,
but a way of being is something that
provides you with something to dine on
on a continual basis,
and so you might say,
well,
is it better to be to have a fish or to
be a fisherman?
That's another way of thinking about it
and obviously it's better to be a
fisherman because then you can get more
fish and so it's one thing to have
something,
but it's another way.
It's another thing completely to know
how to generate good things and so if
you had any sense,
you'd take the ladder over the former,
even though the former is more
instantaneously gratifying and requires
less work and responsibility.
And so anyways,
the way I'll opens his mouth and goes
chasing these fish and Pinocchio tries.
He's trying to get the hell out of
there.
Even though he wants to find the whale.
When he actually sees the whale,
he leaves he.
And that's also a very common
mythological,
what would you call it?
Plot element.
It's very frequently that what happens
when the hero first sees the terrible
thing,
the dragon say the terrible thing that
he's come to conquer.
He freezes and gets the hell out of
there because it's far worse than you
thought it was going to be and so
Pinocchio.
It's like,
no way man.
I'm not going.
When you hear that whale way,
he swims and he's actually at the
forefront of all the fish,
which is quite interesting too.
So it meantime,
monster was opened.
His mouth and the are pouring in Japan.
I was fishing like mad and he's catching
fish like crazy and so the little cat is
Japan was flinging the fish backwards
into this box and the little cat is
there whacking them to to kill them
while they're flopping around and so
they're.
They're pretty excited about this
because they have a problem.
The problem is how to get out of the
whale.
That's the actual problem,
but a nasty problem inside that is how
not to starve to death and so Japan was
pretty happy that even though he's not
getting out of the whale,
that he gets to have something to eat.
So you could say as well that he's not
exactly focused on the right thing.
He's focused on the micro problem
instead of the macro problem and that
makes them kind of blind.
So anyways,
the whale swallows up.
Pinocchio and Japan are keeps fishing
and then he snags Pinocchio.
Now this is cool because,
and this is another example of that Meta
fish idea is like you better was
actually looking for a fish.
He's looking for a way out of the day.
I'm whale and then he catches a bunch of
fish and he's focused on like mad and
then he couches Pinocchio.
Pinocchio represents what would get them
out of the whale,
but he's so bloody obsessed with the
fish that he doesn't even notice.
So we catch this Pinocchio and flings
them into the fish basket.
And so it signifies the blindness of
Japan orientation in India as it.
When he's inside the way on that,
that's kind of a comment on his,
his aged and insufficient nature.
He's solving the wrong.
He's solving the problem very well,
but it's the wrong problem.
So anyways,
he fires Pinocchio into the Fish Pen and
Pinocchio says,
Father,
I'm here in Japan.
No says,
don't bother me right now.
Pinocchio.
I'm busy fishing so.
Well then that's fine.
So then he kind of wakes up.
He has this little moment of insight,
this little revelation that while he's
caught Pinocchio's who cares about the
damn fish.
So then he runs over to the fish box to
grab Pinocchio and instead he grabs a
fish and gives him a kiss.
And so that is another way of hammering
home the fact that he's,
there's this confusion that he's
suffering from.
He can distinguish the local truth from
the,
from the transcendent truth.
And so anyways,
he does figure it out.
He tosses the fish aside and he grabs
Pinocchio and they're all thrilled to
death to see each other.
And,
and so they're united.
So Pinocchio has found his father,
but they're still trapped in the belly
of the whale.
Now Pinocchio takes off his hat,
he gets covered with a blanket,
he takes off his hat and he reveals his
jackass ears,
and so he's found his father,
but he but he's,
he's damaged,
did not put Lko is he's damaged,
did not in good shape.
He isn't becoming what he was supposed
to be.
In fact,
he's actually degenerated since,
since Japan.
I saw him last and so he becomes
embarrassed and he says he has a tale.
He says,
that's nothing.
I have a tail too.
And then he spins that around,
kind of laughing and braise and gets
really embarrassed,
and so that's what you see here.
It looks like.
Well,
he's revealed himself as a jackass to
his father,
but you know,
that's actually a good thing because
he is a jackass and if he was unwilling
to admit his insufficiency,
he wouldn't have ever gone on this
pursuit.
So
it's this perverse willingness to know
that he isn't all that he could be.
That's part of what drives him to find
everything that his father represents.
Oh,
it's a mission of.
It's a human.
It's a humility and it's an admission of
insufficiency.
And you need that before you're going to
learn anything,
because before you learn anything,
you have to admit that there are things
that are important,
that you don't know,
that you're a fool and maybe that you're
a brain jackass.
And so that's why there are injunctions
in many religious writings that are
positively portrait humility positively
as the antidote to.
That's the right
way of thinking about it is that
humility means I still have something to
learn.
I still have something to learn.
I'm in sufficient.
It's exactly the opposite.
Say of lamp wakes attitude.
Anyways,
Japan,
oh,
decides that sun puppet who's half
jackass is better than no sun at all,
which is another indication of his
relatively positive orientation towards
the world.
And they reunite and then put it on cue,
immediately sets his eyes on the main
problem.
It's like,
Hey,
we're stuck in this whale.
We need to get out of here.
And it turns out that Japan has already
built a raft,
but there's a problem.
And the problem is,
is that as Japan,
Oh,
says Pinocchio says,
well,
we'll wait for his mouth to open in
Japan.
Oh,
says that doesn't work.
Because when he opens his mouth,
monster opens his mouth,
everything comes in and nothing goes out
so raft,
fine.
But there's no way of using it.
And so Japan,
oh,
decides that they're not going to bother
with that problem and they're going to
go have some fish.
But Pinocchio,
his eye is still on the main prize.
He thinks,
no way,
man,
we're getting out of this whale.
That's the fundamental thing.
We're not going to rearrange the deck
chairs on the titanic.
We're going to attend to the fact that
it's sinking.
We're going to keep our eye on the
primary problem.
So he's a little more awake by now.
So Pinocchio says,
we'll make a fire now.
That's cool.
I think because he's down in chaos,
whereas father is trapped in,
the first thing he does is to use fire.
And of course that's exactly what people
do,
right?
Because we're fire users and so this and
Shaman,
for example,
our masters of fire,
but it's,
there's this really primordial element
to the story right here and it's an
indication that the,
that the thing that can transform order
into chaos,
into productive order results,
so the same spirit that mastered fire
and so Pinocchio lays that out and he
says,
we're going to build a fire and a Japan.
Oh,
says and we'll fill them up with smoke.
And Japan says,
great smoked fish.
So he's still stuck on this whole fish
thing.
And so Pinocchio runs around gathering
up all the spare wood on the boat,
including the furniture which he starts
to break.
And Japan.
Oh,
says,
well,
what are we going to sit on while we eat
or smoked fish?
And Pinocchio Basically says politely
enough with the Damn Fish thing.
I'm going to fill the whale with smoke.
And uh,
that's gonna.
Make them sneeze and then we can get the
hell out of here.
And,
and Japan.
Oh,
says that's gonna.
Make them mad.
It's not a good idea.
And well,
I would say that that's the stance of
the benevolent state against innovation,
you know,
even if the innovation is positive and
even if it's transformative and freeing,
the old state,
even if it's good,
is going to stand in opposition to that.
And so that's also something that's very
useful to know because otherwise you can
get bitter about that.
Anyways,
Pinocchio makes this big Fire Shapiro's
pretty worried about it and he starts to
fill the way up with smoke.
And so this is where the whale turns
into a fire breathing dragon,
which is quite cool.
It's like in sleeping beauty maleficent
turns into a fire spewing dragon as
well.
And if you watch the little mermaid
that,
what's her name,
that Ursula,
she turns into a gigantic snake like
creature as well,
although she doesn't exactly spew fire,
but the transformation of the ultimate
monster into something like a dragon is
very,
very common because it's the ultimate
symbol of the unknown for a variety of
reasons that we'll discuss later.
So anyways,
yes,
it's a symbol of chaos.
Anyways,
and this is quite a horrifying scene.
When my son watched,
he watched Pinocchio when he was about
four and he watched the scene over and
over and over and over.
I don't know how many times he watched
that movie,
but it must've been 100 times,
but he was really fascinated by this
seat and you know,
he was,
he was like locked onto it.
It was frightening,
but there was something in it that he
was processing and,
and cordoning onto.
So anyways,
you see the whale is starting to prepare
to sneeze and it's belting out huge
quantities of smoke and fire and
Pinocchio and Japan Eto and the cat and
the,
and the,
uh,
and the Goldfish bowl are all on the
raft trying desperately to get out of
the way whale which inhales and pulls
the back and then sneezes and pushes
them forward.
And at some point they actually break
free and there's a good gates of hell
image there with the whale belching
smoke like mad and its jaws open.
And so they are a paddling madly away to
get away from this whale.
And the whale is very angry.
Just as you peddle a suggested.
And there's interesting sound effects
that go along with this,
that whale actually turns into a
what happened when your phone is smarter
than you are?
Um,
the way I'll actually turns into
something that's like a locomotive and,
and the sound effects become industrial.
So it's this monstrous machine like
locomotive dragon that's bent on the
destruction of,
of,
of Pinocchio.
And you could say it's an amalgam of
natural and social forces completely
unleashed.
Everything's unleashed against Pinocchio
and his father.
And so they're having a hell of a time.
There's big waves and there and they end
up the way I'll actually abandons them,
but before it does that,
it nails them with its tail and blows
the raft into smithereens.
And so then they're both in the water
and Japan and Pinocchio or drowning and
Japan.
No,
actually goes down for the third time,
so to speak.
And as he's going down,
he says to Pinocchio,
Save Yourself,
save yourself.
And so that's kind of Pinocchios last
temptation because Japan has had it and
he could just get to shore on his own,
but he would have abandoned his father.
And so that's the thing is,
and that's one of the issues that this
movie grapples with,
is what exactly is your responsibility?
And you can say,
well,
it's to save yourself,
but the myth that underlies this says,
no,
it's not.
That's not exactly right,
is to rescue your father from the
chaotic depths and integrate with that
and to save both.
And that's your duty to your culture.
But more than that,
it's also your duty to your soul.
It isn't going to work if you just save
yourself because you're still going to
be a jackass puppet,
even though you're going to be back on
shore.
So anyways,
Pinocchio Grabs Jus Pedo and carries
them to shore and the whale shows back
up and gives them one more good wallop.
And then we see everybody on shore and
it's peaceful again.
Japan is on his back on the dry land and
the kitten washes up and the Goldfish
bowl washes up and the cricket washes
up.
He's been outside the whale all of this
time.
And we see the cricket calling for
Pinocchio.
And then we see him lying in a pool of
water depth.
So he's died rescuing his father,
he died well,
why?
Well,
he is a jackass,
puppet,
and maybe he was supposed to die if he
rescued his father because that
insufficiency that characterized him is
something that's destroyed by the
process of encountering the chaos,
which it was so difficult.
It reforms the personality and the same
occurs when he rescues his father and he
incorporates that.
So it's like
Bilbo in,
in the,
uh,
in the first part of the,
what is it called,
the Lord of the rings,
the Hobbit.
He's this sort of jackass,
puppet guy,
little overprotected shire dweller at
the beginning,
and he goes on this tremendous adventure
and he has to develop the negative parts
of his character.
He actually has to become a professional
thief and he has to develop his bravery.
And so they old personality and sunsets
has to die to give life to the new one.
And so
you see in,
in the Harry Potter series to at the
very end part dies and then his
resurrected right?
That's,
that actually happens to a slightly
lesser degree in the second movie where
the resurrection is aided by the Phoenix
tears after he gets eaten by that,
or he gets chomped by that big snake,
which is roughly speaking the same thing
that's happening here.
Sorry about that.
Okay,
so anyways,
but don't kill us dead.
That's not good.
So the next scene,
we see them back at home and he's lying
dead on the bed and Japan and,
and everyone else are mourning his loss.
And then the blue.
Then we see this magic transformation
and we hear the blue fairies
voice and so it's like he's pushed
himself to his limits and the natural
process kicks back in and revive and
fires him,
but now he's no longer a jackass.
Puppet.
He's actually something that's real.
And so then he tells,
he wakes up,
but he notices that now you know,
he's under gun this proper
transformation.
He notices his hands in particular.
Then he and then he tells Japan who
refuses to even notice.
He says,
no,
don't kill your dad.
Lie Down.
So you know,
Pinocchio convinces him that he's not
dead.
And then in celebration they start the
clock again and so time kicks back in at
that point and so then they have a big
celebration.
Music happens again because this is a
celebratory moment and they dance and
the harmony is restored.
The good old guy has his son and so the
house is properly set up and the old
state has its vision and its capacity
for transformation and the thing that
transforms how's the stability of the
culture behind it and so perfect.
And then the cricket goes outside and
he's talking to the star and the blue
fairy it.
He says he's pretty happy about how this
has gone.
And so then she gives him this little
metal which is made out of gold and it's
a sign in.
It's a Mandela Hall at the same time.
And so it's.
And it's made out of gold and gold is a
noble metal.
It doesn't mate discriminate
indiscriminately with other metals.
It doesn't tarnish.
And so it's.
It's a metal that represents the sun.
And then he flashes his little badge at
the star,
establishing a relationship between his
function as the proper conscience.
And his orientation towards the highest
good and that's it there.
So he's got this little son,
he's wearing this little son.
Uh,
so he's also transformed and developed
as a consequence of this entire process.
And now his Pinocchio's conscience is
properly oriented.
It's oriented towards the highest value.
And then the movie closes and that's,
but don't kill.
So I'll give you a minute and I'll take
some,
take some questions and try to figure
out how to shut my phone off.
So does anybody have any questions?
Yes.
Vaguely.
Psychoanalytic approach to kind of
extracting me articulated messages from
the mythology,
getting the stories and the religion
that's developed over time.
So could you almost say that those are,
um,
kind of constructing this to a societal
level?
These are kind of the dreams of the
collective unconscious.
Sure.
Just exactly what they are.
They're a collective founder of the
fantasies of the collective unconscious.
So that's one way of looking at it.
I mean,
they also take us socio social,
socially determined form,
right?
Because it's animated and that's,
that's uh,
technology and,
and it's obviously something that exists
in a particular time and place.
But yeah,
it's a collective attempt to give voice
to the oldest of a behavioral patterns.
So here's one way of thinking about
that,
which we'll talk about it in some
detail,
which you should have read about at
least to some degree already.
The question is where is that knowledge
represented and younger would say,
well,
it's part of the collective unconscious
and it's.
It's got a biological origin,
but
his,
his description of the biological nature
of the collective unconscious is quite
ambiguous and I think that that's
because it actually is ambiguous.
Like for example,
we know that primates and humans in
particular are at least biologically
predisposed to be afraid of snakes,
so we can learn that very easily.
Now you could make a case that it's more
than biological predisposition that it's
actually built in,
but I would say the predisposition id is
actually a better one because you would
need the exposure to the snake to get it
going.
So,
so that would take place as a
consequence of your experience.
So it's not purely biological,
although it is the case that snake fear
tends to become more intense as you get
older.
Which is not necessarily what you would
expect and the.
I just read a paper this week,
localizing snake fear in primates and it
was hypothalamic to really old,
so because the hypothalamus is a very,
very old part of the brain.
It's older than the Amygdala.
The amygdala is involved in snake fear
as well.
It's really,
really old.
So you could say,
well,
you're prepared to develop snake fear,
like you're prepared to develop language
and like you're prepared to walk by your
biological structure.
Now,
whether that actually constitutes the
contents of your memory,
which is what young seems to imply is an
open question,
but it doesn't really matter because.
So
one time when I went to visit my nephew,
he was running around in a night suit.
He was only about four or five,
so he's acting out this
mythological pattern roughly speaking,
and you'd say,
well how did he know how to do that?
And the answer would be,
well,
it was represented all around them in
the culture,
in fragments,
and like kids are pretty good at putting
fragments of stories together.
That's,
that's really what understanding is,
is to put fragments into story form and
so he'd watched Disney movies and neat
and his parents had read him stories and
he did pretend play with the other kids
and all of those were like exemplars of
this underlying narrative.
There are variants of it and because he
can abstract and generalize,
he's pulling out the central features of
those narratives to hear the heroic
features and then embodying them so
could say,
well the central features of these
narratives are fragmented and
distributed around across the entire
culture and so they don't have to be
exactly inside your head.
They don't have to be part of your
memory.
There are distributed in the behavior
and the actions and the stories of the
entire culture and they just.
You can put them together out of that
so.
And people do that.
That's why they're so hungry for stories
like Whoa,
like this one or like star wars or star
trek or like the marvel movies are like
Harry Potter.
Yeah.
What you said about the last scene on
watching me over and over again,
my little brother did the same thing
with the last first Harry Potter you got
with the two faces.
Watch that.
Probably 20 or $30.
Yeah.
It's really interesting watching little
kids interact with.
Because movies are unbelievably complex.
I mean,
you know,
by the time you're your age and you've
seen,
you know,
several hundred of them at minimum,
the impact wears off,
but it's really something sitting down
with a four year old who hasn't watched
very many movies and walking through one
with them.
I mean there are so turned on.
It's just.
I took my daughter when she was too
young actually.
I took her to see the mask that Jim
Carrey movie Jesus.
I mean she,
she,
she survived it.
I don't think I traumatized her,
but she was sitting on my lap,
but it was really like a gripping a
bundle of barbed wire.
She was just like that,
the entire movie,
you know,
and halfway through I thought,
well that's probably a little too much
psychophysiological intensity for one
small body,
you know,
but she,
it was movies,
they just have a massive impact on
little kids and they will do exactly
that.
They'll watch it over and over and over
and you think what is,
what are they doing exactly how they're
trying to understand.
They're gripped by.
They're gripped by it somehow.
Right.
And it's like there are deeply curious.
They know there's something in it and
they're turning to extract out what it
is and they'll repeat it and repeat it
and repeat it and repeat it and repeat
it.
So they're hungry for the information
because it's part of rescuing their
father from the chaos.
That's one way of thinking about it.
So other questions?
Well,
good enough.
Then.
Let's call it a day.
What is one more question?
In maps of meaning that you keep
returning to the boat when you first
encounter the unknown.
It's like fearful.
Yep.
You're the idea of archetypes.
Are there other kinds of meaning that
people will find new information that's
already patterned into them,
it's patterned into them or into the new
information that's pattern into them by
the architect.
Do people actually,
sure while they project the project,
the contents of their fantasy onto the
unknown thing and partly
partly a process of self discovery,
you know,
so for example,
let's say that you,
you know,
you're gripped by love at first sight or
something like that.
Now you don't know anything about the
person that you're tremendously
attracted to,
but you'll have fantasies about them and
not found.
In fact,
your image of them is a fantasy and if
you take that fantasy apart,
you'll find out what you value.
So you are projecting,
you're projecting yourself into the
world and you can discover,
I mean you may also discover something
about them because there may be elements
of them that matched the ideal quite
nicely.
If you're fortunate and if your ideal is
to have a reasonable sort,
but you can,
you can.
You definitely encounter yourself when
you look at the unknown because you use
your.
Use your fantasy to structure the
contact.
The fundamental structuring is the
heroic encounter with a without known
because that's the pathway.
That's the fundamental pathway of human
beings because we're information
foragers fundamentally,
so it's automatic responses,
fantasies as well that are part of the
first [inaudible].
Sure,
sure.
Well,
that's all also.
Yes,
absolutely.
That's exactly right.
Yes.
So Mindy,
imagine this,
imagine that you're attracted to someone
in York too,
terrified to go speak to her.
Well,
what's happening while you have a
fantasy of a judge and that's your
imagined representation of your own
insufficiency in relationship to the
ideal,
and you project that on this person as a
judge and then you're too paralyzed to
even open your mouth around her.
Very common experience.
Okay,
we should,
let's call it a day.
We'll see you in a week.